RESERVE GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE OVERSEE HEARING OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE TO ORDER TODAY WILL
BE DISCUSSING THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS IDENTIFIED BY
THE STATE AUDITOR THE AUDIT
REPORT RELEASED IN NOVEMBER
TITLED K. THROUGH TWELVE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA THE
STATE'S APPROACH HAS NOT
INSURED THAT SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING IS BENEFITING STUDENTS
AS INTENDED. TO CLOSE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS ORDER THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR WHATEVER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA FOR
REQUESTING THE ON IT- WITH
NEARLY SIX MILLION STUDENTS IN
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE GRADE
LEVELS AND POP SCHOOLS THE
STATE BY. THE END OF DAHLE.
CALIFORNIA'S IMPLEMENTED THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
OR ELSE EFF AS IT IS KNOWN
WHICH SIMPLIFIES THE WAY THE
STATE PAYS FOR SCHOOLS
DIRECTING. ADDITIONAL MONEY TO
DISTRICTS WITH HIGH PROPORTIONS
OF INTENDED STUDENT GROUPS
UNDER THIS CURRENT SYSTEM THE
STATE DISTRIBUTES MONEY TO
DISTRICTS THERE'S THREE
SEPARATE BUCKETS. BASED FUNDS
THAT ALL DISTRICTS RECEIVE
BASED ON STUDENT ATTENDANCE.
AND ADDITIONAL CONCENTRATION
AND SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDS THAT
DISTRICTS RECEIVE BASED ON
THEIR PROPORTION OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE LOW INCOME ENGLISH
LEARNERS ARE FOSTER YOUTH.
OVERALL CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS RECEIVED 90% OF THE
MORE THAN SIXTY TWO BILLION.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION A PORTION THROUGH LC
FF IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. ABOUT NINE
BILLION OF THAT SIXTY TWO
BILLION CONSISTED OF
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
FUNDS. ACCORDING TO THIS ON THE
STATE'S APPROACH TO ELSE EFF
HAS. ENSURE FUNDING IS
BENEFITING INTENDED STUDENT
GROUP CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS. DOT ALSO. BUILT POLICY
BIGGER AND STAY ORDERS LACK
ADEQUATE IF. TO TEST THE IMPACT
OF SUB TOLL AND CONCENTRATE
FUND ON THE- OUTCOMES OF THE
INTO STUDENT. HOPEFULLY THIS
HEARING WILL FOR US THE MEN ON
HOW BEST TO ENSURE THAT FUNDS
ARE BE A LEAD ALEX PROGRAM OUT
IT. TO THE INTO THE AND- TO THE
GROUP AND HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE A COPY OF
THAT- PLEASE CONTACT THE- JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR A COPY OF THAT
STATEMENT- WE DO EXPECT SINCE-
THE GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION
WAS NOT ABLE TO ATTEND TODAY
THAT THEY WILL BE ADDRESSING
THESE ISSUES. AND WE EXPECT TO
SEE SOME OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
FROM THE AUDIT REPORT TO BE
SEEN IN PERHAPS- BUDGET TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. NOW WITH THAT I
WILL GO AHEAD AND- ASK IF
ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
OPENING COMMENTS. I DON'T
REMEMBER WEBER PLEASE YES
PLEASE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WANT TO THANK THE TEAR IN THE
MEMBERS HERE OF THE- AUDIT
COMMITTEE FOR UP SCHEDULING
THIS HEARING TODAY- I THINK-
IT'S AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
HEARING IS. AS MOST OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS ARE WITH REGARDS TO
THE OUR RESPONSIBILITY IS
LEGISLATORS TO OF TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
GOING IN THE PLACES WHERE WE
THINK THEY SHOULD GO. IF
THERE'S SOME SENSE OF
RESPONSIBILITY FOR DOING THAT I
DON'T THINK THE CHAIR FOR
HOSTING THIS IMPORTANT. MEETING
ACCOUNTABILITY MATTERS TO THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA WERE NOT GETTING
THE EDUCATION THAT THEY NEED OR
THAT THEY DESERVE-
UNFORTUNATELY THE AUDITOR AND
HER TEAM OF INVESTIGATORS HAVE
DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB WITH THEY
HAVE CONFIRMED. WHAT MY FEARS
WERE FROM BEGIN. MANY PER
MEMBER SIX AS SIX YEARS AGO WAS
WE START LCF HALF. IN THAT
DISCUSS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND OTHERS WASN'T DISK.
THE COUNTY. I USED IT TO THEM.
YOU COULD NOT. AND NOT A WHOLE
THEM ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE AT MY
WILL NOT GET TO THE CHIU THAT
IT OF THE GOVERNOR I WAS. OF
TOO CONCERNED ABOUT IT NICKEL
DIE AND PAY THAT CAME INTO THIS
AND WHAT WAS GOING AND SO HE
PROBLEM WAS THAT WE WOULD HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY WE WOULD HAVE
THE ABILITY MEASURE AND THAT WE
HAD REGIONALLY HAVE PUT IT INTO
THE LEAD INTO THE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION- WHICH WAS THEN
TAKEN OUT. AND KICKED OVER TO
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
AND IT BEEN SO YEARS AND WOULD
STILL LOOKING THAT ACCOUNT. MY
GREATEST FEARS CAME WHEN I WENT
FROM DISTRICT TO DISTRICT IN
SAN DIEGO NOT ONLY IN SENATE
COUNTY BUT IN THE OTHER EAR IN
AT THE CRITIC QUESTION. WHAT IS
HAPPENING. IS NINE FOR THE
CHILDREN TO CLOSE IT. GAP I
NEVER GOT A GOOD CHANCE. WANTED
TO I THINK ONE DISTRICT
ACTUALLY TOLD ME WHAT THE HOW
MUCH THEY GOT. AND WHAT THEY
DID WITH IT. WE'VE EVEN HAD
HERE. AT THE CAPITAL WITH THE-
FINANCE DEPARTMENT. AND ASK THE
CRITICAL QUESTION HOW MUCH
MONEY ARE WE GIVING FOR THE OF
THOSE PARTICULAR GRANTS. THEY
CLAIM THEY COULDN'T TELL US
THEY DID NOT KNOW THE NUMBERS.
SAID YOU MEAN YOU WRITE CHECKS
AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHO YOU
WRITE THEM TO. AND THEY SAID
WELL NOT REALLY ACID BUT IF YOU
DO THEN YOU SHOULD BE FIRED
BECAUSE YOU'RE IN CONFLICT. NO
SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO CHECK
NOT KNOW WHOSE RECEIVING THAT
CHECK. AND THOSE ARE THE KINDS
OF CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD FOR
THE LAST SIX YEARS AROUND THIS
ISSUE OF ELLE CFM. AFTER MUCH
FRUSTRATION OF TRYING TO WRITE
LEGISLATION TO GET
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND HAVING IT
HELPED IN COMMITTEE AND HAVING
IT BE TELL BY THE GOVERNOR TOP.
IT BECAME A- TO ME THE I ONLY.
WAS BEST. YOU'LL SEE A- I KNEW
AT THAT BUT WE WERE BASS.
DETERMINE WHETHER NOW THE MONEY
GOING TO CHILDREN IT SHOULD GO
TO. SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE CONVERSE. TODAY I PRE THE
RIVER. THAT BEEN DONE. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY
MAKING SURE THAT WHAT WE DID
WITH LCF AFTER THOSE DOLLARS.
THAT WOULD TRULY DESIGNED TO
HELP THOSE CHILDREN WAS
STRUGGLING IN THE STATE. THAT
WE SOMEHOW ANOTHER GET TO THE
POINT WITH THAT WAS DOLLARS GO
TO THOSE CHILDREN. AND THAT WE
CAN FIND A TALK ABOUT. IMAGE
GAP WITH SOME OF THE PROGRAM
AND- IS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR APPEARING IN BANK ARE. I
WILL HAVE. THANK YOU MISS WEBER
WILL BRING FROM ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FOR SILVA. GOOD MORNING AM AS
MEMBER SHARE QUIRK RIP NORTH OR
CAN'T. BUT ALSO A CLASSROOM
TEACHER FOR THIRTY YEARS AND AS
I WAS. UP HERE BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWELVE AND THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA WAS
BEING DISCUSSED I DISTINCTLY
REMEMBER BEING IN A MEETING
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S TEAM AT
THAT TIME GOVERNOR BROWN AND
DOCTOR WEBER AND THERE WERE
SEVERAL OF US AS WE WERE
EDUCATORS BEING. THE TOP TWO
ABOUT HOW THIS MIGHT LOOK IN
THE FUTURE OF ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I ALWAYS REMEMBER IS
DISTRICT WORK CONSTANTLY
TALKING ABOUT THEY WANTED MORE
FLEXIBILITY. THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO USE THE MONEY THE LOCAL
LEVEL AS THEY THOUGHT IT WOULD
BE- BEST FIT FOR THEIR
PARTICULAR DISTRICTS AND I DO
REMEMBER MY COLLEAGUE ARE YOU
MIGHT NOT REMEMBER SAYING- THE
A B. MINUS LOOK CONTROL FUND
FOR. IS BY AID ABOUT WHETHER A
TRIAL IS LEARN TO READ BASS
BALANCING ABOUT UNITS THAT BUT
I ALL OUR BIKE A TRAIN OR
WHATEVER WHERE THEY COULD DO
THEIR THE STANDARD WOULD BE
THAT WE WILL GET THE ARE SO TO
RE AGES A IT WAS. IT WAS REALLY
GIVING A NOD TO THE DISTRICTS
REGARDING- WE WON'T WE TRUST
YOU THERE'S A DIFFERENT WAY TO
FUND OUR SCHOOLS AND SO THAT
MOVE FORWARD- BUT I'VE BEEN IN
THE CLASSROOM. FOR THIRTY YEARS
IN A VERY HIGH ACHIEVING
DISTRICT FULLER TO AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
ALL MY FOUR KIDS HAVE ATTENDED
THOSE DISTRICTS SO I HAVE A
HIGH REGARD FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION. BUT THE TRUTH OF IT
IS THAT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
SUPPLEMENT GRANTS RELATED TO
OUR E. L. LEARNERS RELATED TO
FOSTER KIDS IN OUR LOW SOCIAL
ECONOMIC- STUDENTS. WE CONTINUE
TO SEE A MAJOR ISSUE BETWEEN
EQUALITY AND EQUITY. AND I HAVE
SEEN FIRST HAND DISTRICT AFTER
DISTRICT SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
AFTER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER AND
PARENTS WHO HAVE A VERY VERY
DIFFICULT TIME AND EVEN BEFORE
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA IT WOULD BE RELATED TO
TITLE ONE FUNDS LIKE WHY DOES
THAT SCHOOL GET TITLE ONE
FUNDS. AND WE DON'T SO AT THE
VERY BASIC LEVEL PERRANCE MANY
TIMES ADMINISTRATORS AND
TEACHERS FEEL THAT THAT'S
UNFAIR BUT WHEN WE ADDED THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
THAT IT WAS OKAY WE GET THIS
MUCH MONEY AND THE FIRST THING
WE HEARD FROM MANY DISTRICTS
WAS. WAIT THE NUMBERS ARE WRONG
WE SHOULD BE GETTING MORE
BECAUSE WE HAVE. MORE STUDENTS
A AND IT'S NOT FAIR BUT THEN
ONCE THE MONEY WAS STARTING TO
BE USED. IT WAS WELL OVER GET
X. AMOUNT OF MONEY IF WE PUT A
READING SPECIALIST AT EVERY
SCHOOL THAT EVERYBODY GETS TO
HAVE THAT READING SPECIALISTS
AND THAT'S EQUAL RIGHT. BUT THE
TRUTH IS SOME SCHOOLS NEED
THREE OR FOUR READING
INTERVENTION SPECIALIST BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THE HIGH NUMBER OF
STUDENTS IN THAT. CATEGORY AND
OTHER SCHOOLS MAY NEED ONE OR
NOT EVEN ONE BUT DISTRICTS AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND
SUPERINTENDENTS ARE HAVING A
VERY HARD TIME MAKING THAT
DECISION BECAUSE IT SEEMS ON
EQUAL. AND THE TRUTH IS YES IF
STUDENTS QUALIFY FOR THOSE
FUNDS THEY SHOULD GET MORE. AND
THAT IS WHERE WE HAVE THIS
EQUITY ANY QUALITY ISSUE AND IT
JUST HAPPENS ALL THE TIME WELL
WE'RE HIRING A P. ET COACH THIS
ISGOOD FOR EVERYBODY. BUT
THOSE FUNDS ARE INTENDED TO
INCREASE THE ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT OF THOSE SUBGROUPS
AND THAT'S WHY I. ASK THE
AUDITOR ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE- THAT I WANTED TO SEE
HOW THESE FUNDS WERE BEING USED
I CAN GIVE MANY EXAMPLES WHERE
THESE FUNDS ARE BEING USED FOR
EXTRAORDINARY THINGS. BUT IS IT
CHANGING HOW THE STUDENTS IN
THESE CATEGORIES ARE ACHIEVING
AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT. I'M
NOT SAYING THAT GROWTH YES WE
SEE SOME OF OUR ACHIEVEMENT
MOVE UP AND THEN WE SEE THE
OTHER STUDENTS MOVE UP AS WELL
SO WE'RE NOT CLOSING THAT SOME
PEOPLE HAVE EVEN GONE AS FAR.
AS SAYING TO ME WE'RE NEVER
GONNA CHANGE CLOSE IT. WE JUST
HOW CAN WAY. AND TO ME THAT'S
NOT ACCEPTABLE SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE HEARINGAND A
BOMB. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU LEAVE US SENATE WAR JUST
HAS A OPENING STATEMENT AS WELL
HOPEFULLY BRIEF. NEARLY BRIEF
THANK THANK YOU CHAIRMAN I JUST
WANTED TO- THANK YOU FOR ALL IN
THOSE WHO PARTICIPATE IN MAKING
THIS THIS AUDIT HAPPEN I THINK
IT'S ALWAYS HELPFUL. WHEN WE- I
TAKE A DEEP DIVE INTO INTO TOP
TO SPECIALLY EDUCATION I'M A
FATHER OF TWO YOUNG BOYS IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL I AM NOW
GETTING VERY WELL VERSED IN
TITLE ONE IN IN THE EDUCATION
PROCESS BUT I'M STILL VERY MUCH
NO IN THE LEARNING PHASE. I DO
WANT TO- JUST MAKE A COMMENT
THAT. AS WE GO THROUGH AND THE
SCHOOLS ARE AUDITED OR AS THE
PROCESS MOVES FORWARD- THAT.
THE REPORT AS IT COMES OUT
POINT IN I. IDENTIFY THAT WALL
SCHOOLS MAY HAVE BEEN PICKED.
SPECIFIC REASONS. ARE THERE
PRACTICES COULD VERY WELL BE ON
UTILIZED BY OTHER DISTRICT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE THING
IS IT POOR DESIGN. SCHOOL ARE
PICKED A ON AFTER WERE LIKE THE
AS THOUGH THE MAY BE ON. AND I
THINK WHAT WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT
IS THAT THERE SOME TO OF MUCH
LARGER PATTERNS IN IN IN
SYSTEMS OF OPERATION SO ALL
LEAVE THAT FOR THE- THE AUDITOR
AND- THE FOLLOWING- THE
FOLLOWING A REPORT. BUT
FLEXIBILITY AT THE LOCAL
CONTROL LEVEL I THINK IS A
CENTRAL I THINK WE MUST
CONTINUE THAT AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WANT TO HEARING WHAT
EVERYONE HAS TO SAY TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR RIGHT
HERE IN SINGAPORE OPENING
COMMENTS I'M SORRY ONE WAS YOU
CAN SAY CONVENES IN. O'CLOCK OR
HEARINGS WILL LET YOU KNOW THAT.
ALL RIGHT WELL. HEARING AND SEE
MORE WAS THE RELAY WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE AN COM. YOU'RE GOOD ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT THANK VERY
MUCH SO WITH THAT LET'S GO TO
GET STARTED LET ME THANK OF ALL
THE MEMBERS OF HERE AT ON TIME
CENTER THIS AS A MORE LOCKS
MEMBER I'VE WAS. ONE OF THE
FIRST ONES HERE- SOME WOMAN
QUIRK SILVA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER SENATOR GONZALEZ AND
pOFFER BEING HEROES WITH THAT
LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
WITH THE FIRST PANEL THE
OVERVIEW THE AUDIT FINDINGS
RECOMMENDATIONS WE HAVE OUR
STEAMED STATE AUDITOR ELAINE
HOW- DEL CARL CARLSON PRINCE
WATER JORDAN RIGHT SENIOR
AUDITOR. AND THAT LET ME JUST
SAY JUST BASED OFF EVERYONE'S
OPENING COMMENTS OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A SENSE OF FRUSTRATION
I BELIEVE FROM LEGISLATURE FROM
SOME OF THE MEMBERS WANTING
SOME INCREASED ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS WE DID HAVE ABOUT
THE L. C. F. F. AT ITS INTENDED
GROUPS ONE OF THE MAIN. WE HAD
THE LC IF TO HELP THESE GROUPS
AND THERE'S A LEVEL FIRST
THAT'S HAPPENING SO I MET
MATTER WHEN YOUR PLEASE THE YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- MEMBERS
FOR THE RECORD MY NAME'S ELAINE
HOW ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR WITH ME IS JORDAN
MISTER RIGHT THE AUDIT
SUPERVISOR EXPERT TO PROJECT
AND- MR CARTOONS NOT AVAILABLE.
HE'S STILL WHAT BILLABLE COME
TO HEARING BUT MR TO WRITE IS
SAM ABSOLUTELY FOR CAPABLE OF
STE YOU THROUGH THE DOCKING.
FOR WHAT LAUNCH INTO AND OUT
THAT GYM PROVIDED TO I'M WOULD
LIKE TO JUST DO A VERY HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW AND THEN I'M MR
RIGHT CAN YOUTH AND STE. ARE
FOR EACH D. IF WE I UP AS
DOCTOR AND QUIRK IN WE WERE AT
DOING AN AVAIL EFFECTS. TO
THREE SCHOOL TRICKS SIMPLY LOOK
BOARD OF EDUCATION BECAUSE
THERE IS. RATED L. TEMPLATE AND
OTHER IT'S A LITTLE BIT WORK
THE PAGE AS WELL AND LOOKING AT
THE DASH AND OUTCOMES IN HOUSE
OF THESE. IN. THREE KEY ISSUE
AREAS THE FIRST IS RELATED TO
FUNDING- AND AS SOME OF THE
OPENING COMMENTS. MENTIONED ARE
THE CONCLUSIONS IN THE REPORT
IS THAT THE STATE HAS NOT
INSURED THAT DISTRICTS ARE
SPENDING SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION FUNDS THOSE FUNDS
THAT WERE SPECIFICALLY PROVIDED
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR THOSE
AS WE REFER TO THEM INTENDED
STUDENTS ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE
AND INDIVIDUALS FROM HOUSE WITH
LOW INCOME SO THOSE THREE
GROUPS. IS REALLY WHAT THE
SUPPLEMENT CONCERT CAN FUNDING
WAS PRIMARILY ALLOCATED FOR AN
AND THE STATE IS NOT ENSURING
THAT THAT MONEY IS BEING SPENT
FOR THOSE STUDENTS AND SO THOSE
STUDENTS ARE NOT BENEFITING
FROM THAT MONEY. AND THE SECOND
AREA I THOUGHT THE ALL CAPS THE
LOCAL CONTROL AND DANCE. AND
WHEN WE- THOSE. AT THE- IS THE
PLANS ARE NOT PROVIDING THE AND
ABILITY TO CALL CAN. TO STAKE.
PARENTS ARE IN THE COMMUNITY
PARENTS OF STUDENTS GOING TO
THOSE PARTICULAR SCHOOLS HOW
EFFECTIVELY THOSE DISTRICTS ARE
PROVIDING SERVICES TO THOSE
INTENDED STUDENTS. AND THEN THE
THIRD MAJOR CATEGORIES OUTCOMES
WE CERTAINLY AS A STATE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO TIE FUNDING TO
OUTCOMES AND AS MS QUIRK SILVA
TRY TO CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP AND- INCREASE THE
ACHIEVEMENT OF THESE THESE
PARTICULAR STUDENTS. AND
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE FOUND IS
THERE IS THERE ISN'T A LINK
BETWEEN THERE ISN'T A DIRECT
LINK BETWEEN THE FUNDING THAT
IS BEING PROVIDED TO THE
DISTRICTS. AND THE DASHBOARD
THAT THAT THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION LAUNCH JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO. SO THOSE ARE THE
THREE BIG BIG BUCKETS THAT
WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT TODAY I
WILL STEP YOU THROUGH VERY
QUICKLY AT A HIGH LEVEL IS A
AND THE INTEREST OF TIME I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. CAN GET TO
THE HAND. BUT I'M FUNDING THEY
SAID STATE DOES X. REQUIRE
DISTRICTS TO SPEND THEIR ALL OF
THEIR SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION FUNDING FOR THESE
INTENDED STUDENT GROUPS.
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WE IDENTIFY
IS IF A DISTRICT DOESN'T SPEND
ALL THEIR SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION FUNDING IN ONE
YEAR. IN THE NEXT YEAR. OF THE
DEATHS WERE YOU DOING THAT AS
BASE FOR IT DID NOT MAINTAIN
ITS ITS IDENTITY. AS
SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
FUNDING SO WE HAD CONCERT WITH
THAT AND MADE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO THAT
SUBSTANTIALLY AS WE CONCLUDE
AND REPORT WITH THE STATE HAS
CREATED A MECHANISM PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR SPECIFIC
DEEPENS. BUT NOT A CAN IS TO BE
ABLE TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT THAT FUNDING IS ACTIVE IS
BE USED BRIT. AND IS A FOR IN.
PORT AU SO THE KIDS. YOU KNOW.
BUT SHE AB IN THEIR CHIEF LEVEL.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE EL CAPS.
WITH RESPECT TO FUNDING WHY WE
SAT FOUND IS BUT IN THE- IN
FOR. RELATED TO SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION FUNDS WAS NOT
ALWAYS TRANSPARENT. WHAT ARE
STAFF AND JORDAN WILL TALK TO
ABOUT THIS LITTLE BIT IS WE
ACTUALLY HAD TO GO INTO THOSE
ALL CAPS. AND LOOK IN VARIOUS
AREAS OF THESE VOLUMINOUS L.
CAPS HUNDREDS OF PAGES TO FIND
ALL OF THE BUDGET INFORMATION
ALL OF THE EXPENDITURE
INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO COME
UP WITH A SUMMARY. OF
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IT ALL SPENT
WHAT WAS IT SPENT ON. AND WE
HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS. IN THE
REPORT AGAIN RELATED TO MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND MAKING THOSE
EL CAPS MORE STREAMLINED. AND
ALLOWING PEOPLE THE ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS BUDGET WHAT
WAS SPENT IS THERE MONEY LEFT
OVER AND BEING ABLE TO HOLD
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR USING THAT MONEY IN THE
FIVE SUBSEQUENT YEAR. FOR THE
INTENDED STUDENT GROUPS. SO
THOSE ARE THE ARE SOME OF THE
ISSUE RELATED TO FUND. THE
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
THE L. CAPS A OUR OUR PRIMER
CONCLUDE ON THIS IS THE
INFORMATION IN THESE CAL CAPS
IT'S OVERLY COMPLEX ON THESE EL
CAPS ARE LONG THE LUMINOUS
DOCUMENTS THEY REALLY NEED TO
BE STREAMLINED- AND WHAT WE
FOUND IS THERE WERE THERE WERE
A VARIETY OF GOALS AND THE ALL
CAPS AND THEN. NUMEROUS
SERVICES. UNDERNEATH THOSE
PARTICULAR GOALS BUT WE WEREN'T
SEEING A LINK BETWEEN THAT AND
THE ACTUAL EXPENDITURE SO IT'S
REALLY OBSCURING. THE ABILITY
REALLY MAKING IT DIFFICULT FOR
STAKEHOLDERS OR ANYONE TO
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT A
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS DOING AND
BEING ABLE TO HOLD THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACCOUNTABLE TO PROPER
USE OF THOSE FUNDS. SO WE HAD
SOME SOME RECOMMENDATIONS WITH
RESPECT TO THAT ARE CERTAINLY
WE ARE UNDER IN THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION WORKING ON STREAM
AND DO SOME. RISE OF THE EL CAP
AND WE THINK THAT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTORY BUT WE ALSO
THINK THAT THERE ARE MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE WITH RESPECT TO THAT
SO I'M GONNA STOP THEIR STARS
THE ALL CAPS AND LET AGAIN
JORDAN TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE
BIT. AND THEN OUT COMES WE WERE
REALLY LOOKING FOR LET. PAINT
AND TING THE L. CAP NO THAT FOR
THERE IS A AN ACT IS NOT THANK
BETWEEN. MY DISTRICT IS. THERE
AND SINGLE MONIES IN AND IS
THAT ULTIMATELY ACHIEVE AN
OUTCOME. SO FOR A- IF A- YOU
RECEIVED AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR
A SLANG LEARNERS. AND THEY HIRE.
AND THAT'S SERVICE THAT THE PER.
TO THOSE STUDENTS WE YOU GET TO
THE DASH. YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO TELL. THE FUNDING
THAT THAT DISTRICT SPENT ON
THOSE TUTORS. SUCH RESULTED IN
INCREASED ACHIEVEMENT FOR
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
BECAUSE IT GETS. IT GETS ROLLED
UP INTO AN OVERALL GOAL SO IT'S
NOT SPECIFIC TO THAT SERVICE OR
THAT PARTICULAR TUTOR AND WE
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
DIRECT CONNECTION BETWEEN. WHAT
ARE WE SPENDING THE MONEY AT
THE DISTRICT SPENDING THE MONEY
ON. AND WHAT ULTIMATELY IS THE
OUTCOME SO YOU CAN MEASURE OVER
TIME NOW THE DASHBOARD WAS
LAUNCHED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
LCF IT'S BEEN AROUND FOR LONGER
THAN THAT START IN FISCAL YEAR
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN. SO WE ONLY
HAVE AS A STATE A COUPLE OF
YEARS OF INFORMATION BUT WE
CERTAINLY BELIEVE THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNE TIME NOW. TO MAKE
SOME CHANGES TO THE
REQUIREMENTS TO ALLOW.
STAKEHOLDERS THE LEGISLATURE
THE PUBLIC TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS MONEY IS
BEING INVESTED AND IS IT TRULY
BENEFITING THE STUDENTS THESE
INTENDED STUDENTS. ARE AND IS
IT RESULTING IN OUTCOMES THAT
ARE SHOWING IMPROVEMENT AND
pACHIEVEMENT GAP SO WE NEED TO
SEE AN ALIGNMENT BETWEEN
EXPENDITURES AND OUTCOMES AND
WITH THAT THAT DOES NOT EXIST
RIGHT NOW WE THINK THERE IS A
SOLUTION. WE THINK IT'S A
FEASIBLE REASONABLE SOLUTION-
TO BE ABLE TO GET THERE- AND
AGAIN AS WE CONCLUDE IN THE
REPORT WE THINK NOW THE
OPPORTUNE TIME. TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT SO WITH THAT
MEMBERS I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER
TO MISTER RIGHT AND HERE HE
WILL STEP YOU THROUGH THE HAND
OUT WHICH WILL BASICALLY. EL
HELP LAPERRIERE'S SOME OF THE
THESE THREE KEY ISSUES THAT I
DE IDENTIFIED. PLEASE MR IT
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JORDAN RIGHT
I'M A SENIOR AUDITOR WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE AND I
WAS THE TEAM LEAD FOR THIS
AUDIT OF. THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA. I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN JUST BY SHARING SOME
BRIEF BACKGROUND INFORMATION
SOME OF IT'S BEEN TOUCHED UPON
ALREADY AND THEN. HAS THE STATE
AUDITOR SETTLE TALK THROUGH
THOSE THREE FINDING AREAS. SO
TO BEGIN WITH IN FISCAL YEAR
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
THE STATE SHIFTED FROM THE
CATEGORICAL APPROACH IT
PREVIOUSLY USED TO THE TO THE-
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
AGAIN THE INTENT BEING TO
PROVIDE THAT LOCAL CONTROL
DISTRICTS BUT ALSO TO REDUCE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS THAT EXIST.
NOW WITH THOSE- INTENDED
STUDENT GROUPS. ON PAGE ONE OF
THE HANDOUT WE SHOW THE
ELEMENTS OF THE- HEALTHY FF.
BASED FUNDS WHICH AGAIN FOR ANY
EDUCATIONAL PURPOSE AND THEN
THE SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION FUNDS. THAT ARE.
TO BE USED TO INCREASE OUR
IMPROVE SERVICES. FOR THOSE
INTENDED STUDENT GROUPS WE ALSO
PROVIDE THERE AT THE BOTTOM A
HYPOTHETICAL EXAMPLE OF HOW
THAT CALCULATION ACTUALLY
WORKS- WHAT I WOULD NOTE IS
THAT. DURING THE PERIOD OF OUR
AUDIT AND REALLY UP UNTIL THIS
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR. THE
CALCULATION HAS ACTUALLY BEEN
PROVIDING A TARGET AMOUNT IT'S
NOT BEEN THE ACTUAL FUNDING
THAT DISTRICTS RECEIVE AN-
THERE'S BEEN A PHASE IN PERIOD
WHILE THE LCF WAS NOT FULLY
FUNDED. AT THE BEGINNING AS
IT'S GROWN ON THE STATE IS
ADDED ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
FULLY FUND IT. THE STATE WAS
USING A OF IN A- IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THAT PHASE IN
APPROACH IDENTIFIED A TOTAL
AMOUNT OF LC FF. THE DISTRICT
WOULD RECEIVE IT DID NOT
IDENTIFY HOW MUCH OF THAT WOULD
BE SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION. SO AS A RESULT
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
HAD TO ADOPT SOME REGULATIONS
THAT WOULD INSTRUCT DISTRICTS.
IN HOW TO IDENTIFY AND
DETERMINE HOW MUCH WAS-
SUPPLEMENT ONE CONCENTRATION
FUNDING. ON PAGE TWO WHAT WE
SHOW. IS SOME OF THE IMPACT IN
THE IMPLICATIONS OF THE
APPROACH THAT THE STATE BOARD
TOOK. AND ULTIMATELY WE FOUND
THAT THOSE REGULATIONS THEY
TOOK AN APPROACH OF BASING
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
FUNDING ON PRIOR YOU'RE
SPENDING. RATHER THAN ON THE
POPULATION OF INTENDED STUDENT
GROUPS AND THAT RESULTED IN
DISTRICTS IDENTIFYING LESS OF
THEIR HEALTHY F. F. AS
SUPPLEMENT ONE CONCENTRATION.
THAN THEY WOULD HAVE IF THEY
HAD FOLLOWED MORE CLOSELY THOSE
PROPORTIONS THAT EXIST. IN THE
FORMULA ITSELF SO THE
HYPOTHETICAL EXAMPLE SHOWS YOU.
THE TARGET AMOUNT- FOR A
HYPOTHETICAL TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IN THAT FIRST BY THE
SECOND BAR IS SHOWING WHAT
WOULD HAVE RESULTED IF THE
STATE BAR THERE THE STATE BOARD
HAD TAKEN AN APPROACH THAT MORE
CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH THOSE
PROPORTIONS YOU CAN SEE THE
TWENTY. PERCENT IN SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION AND 80% AND THEN
THE LAST BARS SHOWING WHAT THE
STATE BOARD ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED- AND YOU CAN SEE
THE DIFFERENCE THERE IN THE
AMOUNTS OF SUPPLEMENT ONE
CONCENTRATION. AT THE BOTTOM OF
THAT FIGURE WHAT YOU CAN SEE
IS. AGAIN THE LIGHT YELLOW ON
THE BOTTOM BUT DISTRICT
ACTUALLY IDENTIFIED USING THOSE
REGULATIONS SO THEY FOLLOW THE
REGULATIONS. AND THE IDENTIFIED
A MOUNTAIN FUNDING AS- WOMEN
CONCENTRATION THE- HOWEVER. IS
GOING AGAIN FOR OUR THREE. THE
M. THAT. WOULD HAVE BEEN I. IF
THEY HAD IF THE STATE HAD USE
REGULATIONS THAT MORE CLOSELY
ALIGNED WITH THOSE. PROPORTIONS
THAT EXIST IN STATE LAW.
JENNIFER A THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DOLLARS OVER THAT FIVE
YEAR PERIOD. AND THAT IS
BECAUSE I DE OR IT SHOWS THAT
BY DEFERRING THAT
IMPLEMENTATION OF SUPPLEMENTAL
IN CONCENTRATION AND ALLOWING
DISTRICTS TO BASE IT ON PRIOR
YOU'RE SPENDING. THERE'S BEEN A-DELAY ULTIMATELY IN THE FUNDING
THAT WAS SPENT FOR THOSE
INTENDED STUDENTS AND LIKELY
THE IMPROVEMENTS IN THEIR
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES SO WE
PROVIDE THIS REALLY AS- AN
EXPECTATIONS SETTING THAT THAT
PERHAPS NOT AS MUCH PROGRESS
HAS BEEN MADE AS MIGHT BE
EXPECTED. I WILL KNOW THAT NOW
THE HEALTHY FF IS FULLY FUNDED
THE FORMULA IS NOW IDENTIFYING
ACTUAL FUNDING AND SO THE
REGULATIONS THAT THE STATE
BOARD HAD ADOPTED ARE NO LONGER
IN PLAY SO THIS IS A HISTORICAL
PROBLEM THAT NO LONGER. NO
LONGER EXISTS. MOVING TO PAGE
THREE- AT THE STATE AUDITOR
SAID- THE FIRST FINDING WAS
REALLY THAT THE DISTRICTS HAVE
AN INSURED IN THE STATES
APPROACH HAS AN INSURER. THE
DISTRICTS SPEND ABOUT FUNDING-
ON SERVICES FOR THE INTENDED
STUDENT GROUPS. AND THEY'RE
REALLY THREE POINTS THAT I WANT
TO MENTION AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY THE STATE
LAW DOESN'T EXPRESSLY REQUIRE
THOSE FUNDS TO BE SPENT AND AS
A RESULT ANY UNSPENT FUNDS CAN
BE USED FOR ANY PURPOSE IN THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. THE NEXT POINT
STATE LAW DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT
DISTRICTS TRACK THIS FUNDING.
IN THEIR ACCOUNTING SYSTEMS
THAT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
IDENTIFY WHETHER OR NOT ANY
UNDER SPENDING OCCURRED. IN
FACT THE EL CAP AND AS THE
STATE AUDITOR MENTION THESE
NUMEROUS. VOLUMINOUS DOCUMENTS
IT'S THE ONLY PLACE THAT YOU
CAN FIND THAT INFORMATION. AND
SO WHAT WE DID IS WE REVIEWED
FOR ON THE THREE SELECTED
DISTRICTS AND THEIR BUDGETED
AND ACTUAL EXPENDITURES IN
THOSE DOCUMENTS. WE FOUND THAT.
THE TWO OF THE DISTRICTS
ACTUALLY UNDER SPENT. THERE
SUPPLEMENT ON CONCENTRATION BY
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. ULTIMATELY
WE MADE THE RECOMMENDATION THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD AMEND
STATE LAW AND REQUIRED
DISTRICTS TO ANNUALLY RECONCILE
THESE AMOUNTS HOW MUCH DID YOU
RECEIVE HOW MUCH DID YOU
BUDGET. AND HOW MUCH DID YOU
ACTUALLY SPEND TO IDENTIFY THAT
ON SPENT FUNDING. AND ANY OF
THE UNSPENT FUNDING WE WOULD
EXPECT THAT IT BE CARRIED OVER
INTO FUTURE YEARS AND TO BE
USED FOR THE PURPOSE THAT IT
WAS INTENDED TO BE USED FOR. I
WILL NOTE THAT THE STATE. THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION HAS
MADE SOME CHANGES TO ITS-
TEMPLATE IT'S ALSO IMPLEMENTED.
A BUDGET OVERVIEW FOR PARENTS
AS PART OF THE EL CAP DOCUMENT.
AND TO THOSE CHANGES THAT
THEY'VE IMPLEMENTED HAVE
INTRODUCED SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION BUT IT DOES NOT.
RESOLVE OUR CONCERN ABOUT
RECONCILING IN CARRYING THOSE
FUNDS OVER. ON THE NEXT PAGE
GETS INTO OUR SECOND FINDING
WHICH IS RELATED TO THE TO THE
L. CAPS. WE FOUND THEY DON'T
CONSISTENTLY PROVIDE THE
TRANSPARENCY THAT WE WOULD
EXPECT. DISTRICTS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SPEND SUPPLEMENTAL
IN CONCENTRATION FUNDS FOR
DISTRICT WIDE PURPOSES
ESSENTIALLY THINGS THAT WOULD
BENEFIT ADDITIONAL STUDENTS
BEYOND JUST THE INTENDED
STUDENT GROUPS BUT WHEN THEY DO
THAT THE REQUIRED TO
DEMONSTRATE IN THE EL CAP THAT
THOSE FUNDS ARE PRINCIPALLY
DIRECTED TOWARD THE INTENDED
STUDENT GROUPS. WE FOUND THAT
THEY DON'T ALWAYS CLEARLY
DESCRIBE THAT IN THE EL CAP.
ACT THIRTY SEVEN OF THE FIFTY
THREE EXPENDITURES THAT WE
LOOKED AT WERE UNCLEAR TO US WE
COULDN'T DETERMINE WHETHER
THOSE ARE PRINCIPALLY DIRECTED.
ADDITIONALLY WE FOUND THAT SOME
STAKEHOLDERS HAD SUBMITTED
CLICK COMPLAINTS TO DISTRICTS
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE AND
CD E. HAD HAD RULED ON THOSE
COMPLAINTS AND ACTUALLY FOUND
SEVERAL THINGS- BULL FROM
PITFALLS AND SOME BEST
PRACTICES. CONSISTENT AMONG
THOSE AMONG THOSE- RESPONSES
THAT THEY PROVIDED. ULTIMATELY
WE MADE THE RECOMMENDATION TO
THE STATE BOARD THAT THEY
SHOULD INCLUDE THAT INFORMATION
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PITFALLS
IN ABOUT THE BEST PRACTICES. IN
THE EL CAP TEMPLATE SO THAT
DISTRICTS KNOW IT AND CAN
EITHER AVOID IT OR MAKE SURE
THAT THEY DO IT AND ALSO ALLOWS
THE COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
TO HOLD DISTRICTS FEET TO THE
FIRE- TO NOT FALL INTO THOSE
THE SAME PITFALLS. THE SECOND
POINT THAT I WANT TO MENTION
THERE IS REALLY THAT THEY THE
INFORMATION RE REVIEWED IN EL
CAPS DIDN'T REALLY COME CLEARLY
COMMUNICATE. HOW THEY WERE
EFFECTIVELY MEETING STUDENTS
NEEDS- AS THE STATE AUDITOR
MENTION THE GOALS ARE VERY
BROAD THERE ARE NUMEROUS
SERVICES. AND THE ANALYSIS THAT
DISTRICTS ARE PROVIDING OUR AN
OVERALL ANALYSIS THEY'RE NOT
LOOKING AT SOME OF THESE
INDIVIDUAL SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY 60% OF THE OUTCOME
DATA THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
THREE DISTRICTS ALL CAPS THAT
WE REVIEWED WAS EITHER PENDING
OR IT WAS LAST YEAR'S DATA SO
AGAIN IT'S NOT IT'S NOT HELPING
YOU TO KNOW IF WHAT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING THIS YEAR. IS
RESULTING IN IN PROGRESS. AND
THEN LASTLY THE LENGTH IN THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE L. CAPS-
HUNDREDS OF PAGES LONG AND
COMPLEX DOCUMENTS. WE MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS AGAIN TO THE
STATE BOARD THAT THEY ADOPT A
TEMPLATE THAT HELPS TO REDUCE
SOME OF THE- DUPLICATION THAT
OCCURS IN THE DOCUMENT BECAUSE
OF. REPETITION WHEN THEY'RE
PROVIDING ANNUAL UPDATES- WE
RECEIVED THEIR RESPONSE AND
REVIEWING IT HELLO GONNA HAVE
SOME IT IN A FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS FOR THE STATE BOARD
ON THAT. ON THAT SCORE. ON THE
LAST FIND THAT I WANTED TO
ABOUT THEM IS AGAIN RELATED TO
THE OUTCOME. AS WE LOOKED AT
THE DASHBOARD DATA FOR THE
THREE DISTRICTS. WE DID SEE
MONSTER PRUDENCE AT THE TIME WE
ONLY HAD TWO DATA POINTS REALLY
TWO YEARS OF DATA. AND THAT WE
ALSO NOTED THAT. OVER TIME.
CHANGES HAVE BEEN MADE TO THE
TESTS THAT ARE BEING USED IN
THERE'S BEEN CHANGES TO THE
DASHBOARD INDICATORS
ALTERNATELY FOUND THAT THEY
CHEAPENED GAPS PERSIST- AND- WE
FOUND. POLICYMAKERS REALLY LACK
ADEQUATE INFORMATION TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE FUNDING
THAT'S BEING USED IS HELPING TO
INCREASE INTENDED STUDENT
GROUPS HI PERFORMANCE. AND TO
REDUCE THOSE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
AS WE POINT OUT IN IN THE
FIGURE ON PAGE FIVE. THERE'S NO
CONNECTION BETWEEN EL CAPS AND
THEIR ACCOUNTING SYSTEMS. AND
THEY DON'T TRACK INFORMATION IN
A WAY THAT ALIGNS WITH THE
DASHBOARD SO YOU CAN NEVER SEE
PROGRESS IN THE DASHBOARD AND
BACK AND BACK TO WORK WITH. ON
TO HELP TO ACHIEVE THAT
PROGRESS IF YOUR SEEN. WHAT'S
BEING DONE THAT SEEMS IN FACT
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT SEEN
PROGRESS. ULTIMATELY WITH TO
ADDRESS THE GAP BETWEEN FUNDING
AND OUT COMES THE STATE COULD
AND SHOULD COLLECTED DIGITAL
INFORMATION. AND WE PROVIDE AN
EXAMPLE SIMILAR TO WHAT THE
STATE AUDITOR MENTIONED IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE- PAYING FOR
ENGLISH. TUTOR YOU SHOULD BE
CAP A AND- IN ACCOUNTING SYSTEM
SO YOU CAN TRACK THOSE
EXPENDITURES. AND THEN THE
STATE OTHER POLICY MAKERS. CAN
COMPARE YOUR SPENDING WITH
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
DASHBOARD. SO WE MADE THE
RECOMMENDATION WE BELIEVE
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
UNDERSTANDING HOW BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ARE ARE IMPACTING
STUDENTS LIVES. AND SO WE MADE
THE RECOMMENDATION THAT THE
STATE DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A
TRACKING MECHANISM TO ACHIEVE
THIS. WE DO NOTE THAT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HE HAS
INCLUDED SOME FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT WHAT HE TERMS AND EL
CAP PORTAL- IT SEEMS TO BE
DIRECTED AT THIS IDEA OF BEING
ABLE TO LINK OUT WHAT YOU'RE
SPENDING WITH WITH- WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE DASHBOARD. IT
DOESN'T ACHIEVE AS FAR AS WE
CAN SEE RIGHT NOW THE CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE ABOUT CONNECTING
THE EL CAP WITH THE ACCOUNTING
SYSTEM SO THAT YOU HAVE LINKAGE
THERE. WE IN THE REPORT PUT
FORTH THE A POSSIBILITY OF
ADJUSTING THE STATE ACCOUNTING
CODE STRUCTURE THAT EXISTS TO
ACHIEVE THIS PURPOSE. SOME
ULTIMATELY AN- CITY AND THE
STATE BOARD- EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT. PERHAPS
RETURNING TO A CATEGORICAL
APPROACH- WE DISAGREE WITH THAT
PERSPECTIVE WHAT WE'RE
RECOMMENDING IS. IMPLEMENTING
AN APPROACH TO IDENTIFY WHAT
DISTRICTS SPENT THEIR FUNDING
ON AFTER THEY'VE MADE THE
DECISION IT WOULDN'T IMPINGE ON
THE DISTRICT'S ABILITY. TO
EXERCISE ITS LOCAL CONTROL TO
CHOOSE OUT WANTS TO SPEND ITS
MONEY IT JUST INFORM
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT WHAT CHOICE
WAS. AND ALLOWS THEM TO THEN
COMPARE WITH OUTCOMES THAT
THEY'RE SEEING IN THE DASHBOARD
ON THE LAST PAGE WE IN SOME OF
THE- WEALTH ISSUES AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE INTENDED
RESULTS ULTIMATELY. WE BELIEVE
THAT BY IMPLEMENTING THESE
LEGEND LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE STATE
BETTER INSURERS THAT
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
FUNDS ARE ACTUALLY BENEFITING
THOSE INTENDED STUDENT GROUPS.
OUT WITH THAT IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER. RIGHT THANK YOU THANKS
FOR THE PRESENTATION AND- WHICH
ONE OF CLARIFY SOMETHING
BECAUSE I'M PRETTY SURE I HEARD
IT CORRECTLY. BUT UNLIKE
CATEGORICAL FUNDS THE L. SAD
LC FF FUNDING IS UNRESTRICTED
MEANING DISTRICTS I CAN USE IT
FOR ANY LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
PURPOSE PROHIBITED BY LAW SO.
IS THERE ANYTHING IN STATE LAW
THAT REQUIRES DISTRICTS TO
SPEND ALL OF THEIR SUPPLEMENTAL
CONSTRUCTION PLANS. ON THESE
THREE INTENDED STUDENT GROUPS.
SO YOU'RE RIGHT THAT THEY ARE
UNRESTRICTED FUNDS MEANING THAT
THEY COULD THEY COULD DECIDE TO
SPEND THE MON BOUNCING
BASKETBALLS ARE PLANTING SEEDS
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
HAD PUT FORTH. THE TYPE OF
SERVICE OR THE THING THAT THE
DISTRICT IS PURCHASING IS NOT.
IS NOT GOVERNED BY STATE LAW.
HOWEVER REGULATIONS REQUIRE
THAT WHATEVER IT IS THAT YOU'RE
BUYING IT NEEDS TO IMPROVE OUR
INCREASE SERVICES FOR THOSE
INTENDED STUDENT GROUPS. GOT IT.
THE YEAH DID SLOT OF QUESTIONS
HERE REG ONE MAKE SURE I GET
THIS FOR THE REC TO SO IF THEY
SPEND THE MONEY ON INTENT
STUDENT GROUPS AND ONE YEAR THE
FOLLOW YEAR. THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE MONEY IS STILL SPENT
FOR THOSE INTENDED STUDENT
CORRECT PRECISELY THERE'S NO
CONTROL THERE THAT'S GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE FUNDING IS
ACTUALLY USED IN SUBSEQUENT
YEARS FOR THOSE GROUPS GOT IT.
MESSAGE HAVE YOU HAD A CHANCE
TO REVIEW THE EL CAP TEMPLATE I
KNOW WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT THE
L. CAP THE STATE BOARD AND CD
EASE- ROLE IN THAT AS WELL BUT-
YOU TOUCHED UPON A YOU SAID
HAVE YOU REVIEWED A LITTLE BIT
OF IT BUT DON'T SEE THAT QUITE.
CLEAR CONNECTIONS WITH HOW THE
MONEY IS BEING ALLOCATED WHAT
IT'S BEING SPENT ON BUT I KNOW
THAT- THE ADMINISTRATION
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. DEPARTMENT
ARE WORKING ON THE AL CAPP
BEGAN. TO READ. LEAVE IT. UP
PRIVY TO ANY OF THOSE JUST. I
YOU DID AUDIT. SEE WHETHER NOT
THIS GOING TO BE ADDRESS. YES
MISTER CHAIR WE WERE IN CALL.
WITH BOTH THE- AND THE STATE
BOARD AS THEY- FOR WE DID GET
TO LOOK AT THEY HAD. I THINK
THREE DRAFTS AND THAT WERE KIND
OF UP FOR CONTENTION AND THEY
WERE DISCUSSING. WE EXPRESSED
OUR- RECOMMENDATIONS TO THEM AT
THE TIME. AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN
COME OUT FROM THE STATE BOARD-
THEY PROVIDED US THEIR THEIR
SIXTY DAY RESPONSE. JUST AFTER
THEY HAD THEIR MEETING TO
APPROVE THE REVISED TEMPLATE.
WHAT WE SEE IN THAT REVISED
TEMPLATE IS THAT THEY HAVE. NOW
INCLUDED SOME ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURE TABLES SO IT KIND
OF PULL THAT INFORMATION OUT OF
THAT THE EL CAP IT SELF AND
PUTS IT IN A TABLE. THE CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE WITH THEIR
APPROACH IS THAT RATHER THAN.
USING THE SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION FUNDING AS A
DISTINCT ITEM THEY'RE TAKING
APPROACH THAT. REALLY ROLLS UP
ANY FUNDING THAT THEY USE
WHETHER IT'S L. CFF
GENERICALLY. ANY OTHER STATE
FUNDING LOCAL FUNDING OR
FEDERAL FUNDING AND THEY ROLL
ALL OF THAT UP AS BEING- AND
IDENTIFY IT AS USED TO ADDRESS
HIGH NEEDS. FOR HIGH STUDENTS
AGAIN OUR CONCERN IS THAT. IT
IT MUDDIES THE WATER REALLY
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
FUNDING IS FEDERAL FUNDING-
LOCAL FUNDING BEING USED TO
SUPPLANT THAT SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION FUNDING IT'S JUST
NOT CLEAR CURRENTLY. GOT IT
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT AND
PROPS LAS THE STATE BOARD AND-
SIR THAT DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WHEN THEY COME UP-
HOW THIS HELPS IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY LIVING THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND. THE CAL
GOLDEN THE TRANSPARENCY ALRIGHT
AB I HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
BUT I KNOW CENTER MORLOCK HAS
QUESTIONS WELL. THANK YOU MAKE
SURE I. FOR THE TIME COULD SHE-
THAT I'M UNDER BUT THAT. OF MS
HOWARD THREE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SELECT. FOR MISTER DIRECTOR
YEAH. AS AS MEN IN THE WE WERE
ASKED LOOK AT THREE LARGE
SCHOOL THIS WE WERE ASKED TO
LOOK AT ALSO GEOGRAPHICALLY
DISPERSED SO WE SELECTED A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. A DISTRICT
FROM CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND
THEN A NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ALL OF WHICH WERE
LARGE AND YOU'RE YOU'RE
REPORTER PERSON REFERS TO FIND
CENTER UNSPENT. I'M JUST
WONDERING SINCE. THERE ISN'T A
MISS OPPORTUNITY HERE BASED ON
WHAT YOU'RE FINDING- THESE
DISTRICTS AT LEAST THE CLOVIS
IS HAVING SOME SERIOUS FISCAL
DISTRESS. COULD THOSE FUNDS BE.
TRANSFERRED TO MAKE A CAL STIRS
PAYMENT OR A PAYMENT. OUR
CONCERN IS THAT IF THEY'RE NOT
SPENT IN THAT FIRST YEAR THERE
REALLY ARE NO CONSTRAINTS TO
THAT FUNDING SO IT COULD BE
USED FOR ANYTHING OR GIVING
THEM A TEMPTATION TO HELP THEM
WITH THEIR DISTRESS AND- YES
POTENTIAL YEAH. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS RIGHT THANK YOU
MISSILE THANK YOU MISTER. YEAH
GO BACK TO THE UNDER. FUNDS
AFTER THE FIRST YEAR OF THIS
WORKS PLEASE. I AM MENTION IN
THE C. D. R. THAT THERE HAD
BEEN SOME. THAT HAD GONE TO THE
C. D. E. N. THERE WERE SOME
PITFALLS AND ALSO I GUESS BEST
PRACTICES CAN YOU JUST GIVE US
A FEW EXAMPLES OF WHAT THAT
MIGHT LOOK LIKE ONLY. ONE THAT
I KNOW JUST OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD IS- IN THAT WE SAW A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WAS USING
CONCLUSORY TYPE STATEMENTS SO
THE DISTRICTS SAYING THIS WILL
BE. PRINCIPALLY DIRECTED-
WITHOUT EVER DESCRIBING HOW
IT'S PRINCIPALLY DIRECTED THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT. CD E. HAD
UPON THAT. THAT'S JUST NOT
ENOUGH IT'S INSUFFICIENT- SOME
OF THE OTHER- ITEMS THAT CD
IDENTIFIED WAS SAYING BASICALLY
THAT A DISTRICT SHOULD EXPLAIN
HOW IT CONSIDERED FACTORS SUCH
AS THE NEEDS CONDITIONS OR
CIRCUMSTANCES OF ITS INTENDED
STUDENT GROUPS AGAIN EXPLAINING
THAT THIS IS THE NEED THAT THE
STUDENTS HAVE AND THEREFORE
WE'RE PROVIDING IT TO ADDRESS
THAT PARTICULAR NEED- IN THE
REPORT WE LIST OUT ALL OF THE-
ALL OF THOSE ITEMS THAT WE
FOUND. AGAIN ANOTHER ONE SIMPLY
STATING THAT THE DISTRICT HAS
HIGH ENROLLMENT PERCENTAGE OF
INTENDED STUDENT GROUPS ISN'T
ENOUGH- BECAUSE SERVING
STUDENTS AS NOT THE SAME AS IN
ROLLING STUDENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DISTRICT WESTERNS I
WOKE AT CAN I JUST ASK BECAUSE
NOT COMPLETELY FAMILIAR WITH
THIS WORLD BUT WHO'S IN CHARGE
OF THE DASHBOARD. THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION I'M JUST AS THE L.
CAPS ARE UNDER THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION YEAH UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION. ALL RIGHT AND
SO FOR US TO GET ALL OF THIS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
I'M JUST. TRYING TO LAY THE
FOUNDATION FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CONNECT. THE DEPARTMENT WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ED. AND THE
CALIBER OF THE OF TRANSPARENCY
THAT WE EXPECT FROM
LEGISLATURE. AND SOME OF THE
DISCUSSIONS AND SOME OF THE
OVERTURES ABOUT THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY
WILL BE VOTED ON. THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA IN THE
FIRST PLACE SO APPRECIATE THE
OVERVIEW- LET'S GO TO JUST MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT PANEL US YOU
HAVE ANY CONCLUDING REMARKS.
NOT AT THIS TIME THANK ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
THIS TIME WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
CALL UP THE NEXT PANEL COMMENTS
AND RESPONSES TO THE AUDIT WE
HAVE ELIZABETH ASK AVAIL SENIOR
DIRECTOR. OF POLICY GOVERNANCE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE
HAVE MISTER BRIAN RIVAS. AS
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
GOVERNMENTAL. GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS EDUCATION TRUST WEST.
I MISS DEBORAH BROWN SENIOR
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
AD GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR
CHILDREN NOW. FEEL LIKE TO
BEGIN PLACE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MORNING COMMITTEE CHAIR MEMBERS
LIVES BUT AVAILABLE CALIFORNIA.
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS
REPRESENTING TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL BUSINESS LEADER
STATEWIDE. WE ARE NONPROFIT
ASSOCIATION THAT PROVIDES
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND THIRTEEN
DISCIPLINARY AREAS INCLUDING
ACCOUNTING FINANCE AND
OPERATIONS. SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF LC FF WE HAVE SEEN A SHIFT
IN HOW THE STATE'S. THE STATE
AIMS TO ALIGN RESOURCES TO
STUDENT SERVICES BASED ON TWO
PRINCIPLES. FIRST TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES TO MORE EQUITABLY TO
STUDENTS. WITH LEARNING AND
SOCIOECONOMIC BARRIERS AND TO
PROVIDE GREATER OPPORTUNITIES
FOR EDUCATORS TO SERVE AND
RESPOND TO THEIR STUDENTS
NEEDS. WHEN THE STATE ADOPTED
THIS NEW FUNDING FORMULA IT
TOOK TIME TO DEVELOP THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE KNOWN AS
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT. WHICH IS
INTENDED TO BE A CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEM. THE STATE'S
GUIDANCE WAS DEVELOPED US AT
THE SAME TIME THAT THE FORMULA
WAS BEING IMPLEMENTED. DURING
THAT TIME CAVS WILL HAVE THE-
TO PARTNER CHILDREN. AND
EDUCATION PRESS LAST TO DEVELOP
USER FRIENDLY TOOLS. TO HELP
PARENTS AND STAKEHOLDERS ENGAGE
IN THE DEVELOPMENT. OF STUDENT
CENTERED STUDENT FOCUSED SCHOOL
BUDGETS. THE MATERIALS BEFORE
YOU ARE EXAMPLES OF WHAT WE
DEVELOPED. SO IF YOU HAVE THE
MATERIALS ON THE LEFT SIDE
YOU'LL SEE THESE. CAVS WILL
HAVE AN ACTIVE STAKEHOLDER
THROUGH THE NUMEROUS EL CAP
TEMPLATE VERSIONS AND BELIEVE
THAT THE LATEST REVISION OF THE
L. CAMP TEMPLATE WHICH WAS
ADOPTED BY THE STATE BOARD ON
TWO JANUARY EIGHTH.
ACCOMPLISHES THE GOALS OUTLINED
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY AND ADDRESS MANY
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS MADE IN
THE ART OF REPORT. SUCH AS
STREAMLINED THE CONTENT AND
FORMAT OF THE EL CAP TO MAKE
THE INFORMATION MORE ACCESSIBLE
FOR PARENTS AND STAKEHOLDERS.
THE INFORMATION ABOUT ACTIONS
IN A MANNER THAT ARE MORE.
SHOWS WHETHER THE INCREASED OR
IMPROVED SERVICES ARE BEING
TARGETED. TO SPECIFIC SCHOOL
SITES OR ON A DISTRICT WIDE
BASIS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THE EL CAP IS A
THREE YEAR PLAN THAT DESCRIBES
THE GOALS. ACTIONS SERVICES. AN
EXPONENTIAL TO SUPPORT POSITIVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES THAT ADDRESS
STATE AND LOCAL PRIORITIES. THE
OUTCOME PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
HOLDS KNOWN AS A LIAISON. TO
SHARE THEIR STORIES OF HOW WHAT
AND WHY PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
ARE SELECTED TO MEET THEIR
LOCAL NEEDS. WE HAVE ALSO
PROVIDED YOU WITH A COPY OF THE
UPDATED I'LL KEPT TEMPLATE.
SHOWN AND IF YOU TO PAGE
NINETEEN WHICH IS THE RED TAB
YOU'LL FIND THEN. ON HOW. HOW
TABLES WILL ALLOW AT LEAST TO
DISPLAY EXPENDITURES AND SPEND
FUNDS IN AND ACCESSIBLE MANNER
WITHOUT THE NEED TO
DISASSOCIATE ALL FUNDS. USED
FOR EACH ACTION. HE JUST TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY
FOUR SHOW HOW THE DATA ENTRY
TABLE TOTAL EXPENDITURE TABLE
AND CONTRIBUTING EXPENDITURE
TABLES ARE BROKEN DOWN. THE
REVISED EL CAP TEMPLATE ALSO
REQUIRES ELEAZAR TO DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN PLAN EXPENDITURES AN
ESTIMATED ACTUAL EXPENDITURES
WITH THE CONTINUED REQUIREMENT
TO EXPLAIN THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BUDGET EXPENDITURES AN
ESTIMATED ACTUAL EXPENDITURES.
IF YOU GOT YOUR FIRST BLUE TAB
ON PAGE SIXTEEN YOU CAN SEE THE
INSTRUCTIONS PROVIDED IN PAGES
TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY SIX. THE
BLUE TAB. AND YOU CAN SEE HOW
THE ACT AND UPDATES FOR. THE
EACH YEAR IS ALSO BROKEN DOWN.
ELLIE IS ALSO PROVIDED THE
INFORMATION FOR EACH ACTION FOR
THE RELEVANT EL CAP YEAR. THIS
INCLUDES WHAT FUNDS ARE USED TO
SUPPORT THAT ACTION. THESE
ACTIONS CAN BE FUNDED FROM LCF
FUNDS WHICH MAY INCLUDE ONE OR
A COMBINATION OF BASE GRANT
SUPPLEMENTAL AND OUR
CONCENTRATION GRANT DOLLARS AND
OR OTHER STATE. OR LOCAL OR
FEDERAL DOLLARS SEEN ON PAGE
TWENTY ONE WHICH IS NEAR GREEN
TAB. CREATING A SET ASIDE
MECHANISM TO RECORD THIS AND-
FELL TO SHOW HOUSE DIST BREAK
RESOURCES TO FUND PROGRAMS AND
SUPPORT STAFF. WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT REQUESTING ELEAZAR TO ONLY
DISPLAY ONE SOURCE OF FUNDING
FOR ONE SPECIFIC ACTION WILL
CREATE FOR THE CONFUSION.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS UTILIZE
MULTIPLE FORCES TO ACCOMPLISH
THE ACTIONS. THAT INCREASE AND
IMPROVE SERVICES FOR STUDENTS
LISTED UNDER EACH SPECIFIC GOAL
BY STATE BY STATE WHY PRIORITY.
FOR A- ASSEMBLY SCHOOL DISTRICT
WITH 89% OF STUDENTS QUALIFYING
AS ON DUPLICATED COUNT DECIDED
TO PROVIDE HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION SERVICE SERVICES
DISTRICT WIDE. TO ADDRESS
CHRONIC AND ACT ABSENTEEISM AND
IMPROVE ACCESS TO BREAKFAST
MEALS. WE ARE CONCERNED WITH
FEATURE CHANGES THAT WOULD
DISCONNECT THE REAL FUNDING
ALLOCATION TO SUPPORT
STRATEGIES AND ACTIONS DEVELOP
AS A COMMUNITY WHICH IS
REQUIRED AS PART OF THE L. CUT
DEVELOPMENT. IT WOULD CREATE
ADDITIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE WORK
TO RECORD INFORMATION IN
MULTIPLE PLACES AND EXPENSE THE
EL CAP BY BREAKING UP REPORTING
BY STAND ALONE FUNDING SOURCES
FOR EACH SERVICE. SCHOOLS ARE
UNDERFUNDED AND MUST USE
MULTIPLE FORCES TO SUPPORT
STAFF AND PROVIDE SERVICES. THE
SUGGESTED METHOD MOVE AWAY FROM
THE REVIEW AND ANALYSIS OF THE
STUDENT ACADEMIC PROGRESS
DURING I'LL CUT DEVELOPMENT AND
INSTEAD FOCUSES ATTENTION ON
INDIVIDUAL BUT LET BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS. WITH THE
ASSUMPTION THAT EACH INDIVIDUAL
SERVICE CAN BE CORRELATED TO
ONE STATE OR LOCAL INDICATOR
FOR. CASUAL BELIEVES THAT
STRENGTHENING THE STATE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM AND
INVESTING AN INTERACTIVE ONLINE
ENVIRONMENT. DEVELOPING
GUIDANCE AND BEST PRACTICES TO
DELIVER SERVICES THAT ACHIEVE
THE GOALS OF CLOSING THE
ACADEMIC CAPS. IN IMPROVING THE
MENTAL OVERALL WELL BEING OF
OUR STUDENTS IS WHAT OUR
EDUCATORS AND ADMINISTRATORS
ARE SEEKING. CAVELL WILL
CONTINUE TO DEL. TO FOCUS ON
STUDENT OUTCOMES AND CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP. THROUGH A
STRONG SYSTEM OF SUPPORT BUT
EMPOWER SCHOOLS AND EDUCATORS
TO MEET THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
THEIRDIVERSE STUDENTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU PLEASE DOES NOT
ABOUT. MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I BRIAN AND I'M SO OF THE
EDUCATE TRUST WEST WERE
RESEARCH POLICY ANALYSIS AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
ON CLOSING OPPORTUNITY AN
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS UP HAVE A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT TAKE ON THE
AUDIT WE WANT TO THANK THE
STATE AUDITOR WE THANK HER
ANALYSIS IS EXACTLY ON POINT IT
IT ALIGNS WITH OUR OWN RESEARCH
AND FEEDBACK FROM COMMUNITY
GROUPS I ALSO WANT TO SAY AT
THE OUTSET WE'RE STRONG
SUPPORTER OF L. CFF. OUT WE SEE
THIS AS AN EFFORT TO LIVE IT OR
TO MAKE IT LIVE UP TO ITS
PROMISE OF EQUITY AND ENSURING
THAT THOSE WHO NEED MARQUETTE
MORE WE'RE NOT TRYING TO CHANGE
THE FUNDING FORMULA WE'RE ALSO
NOT INTERESTED IN TYING THE
HANDS OF DISTRICTS IN ALTERING
THE RULES REGARDING HOW
DECISIONS ARE MADE WE JUST WANT
TO SEE THOSE DECISIONS. AND
SURE QUICKLY. ADVOCATES IN
OTHER STATES ARE LOOKING TO SEE
WHETHER. ELSE HAS WORKED THERE
THERE CONSIDER SIMILAR. THEIR
FIRST IS IT WORK. SECOND
QUESTION IS. DID THE STUDENT
FOR THE ARGETS BENEFIT. SO WE
THINK THOSE ARE THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS- WITH REGARD TO DID
IT WORK A DIP DEPENDS VERY MUCH
ON WHO DO WHO YOU ASK WE HAVE A
MIXED BAG WHEN IT COMES TO
OUTCOMES WE HAVE SOME
PERSISTENT GAPS IN OUR
STANDARDIZED TEST SCORES BUT
THERE IS SOME PROMISING NEWS ON
THE A THROUGH G. COMPLETION AND
GRADUATION FRONT. BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO DO THE INTENDANT
STUDENTS BENEFIT WE REALLY NEED
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION BECAUSE
THEY'RE SHOCKED WHEN WE WHEN
YOU TELL PEOPLE IN OTHER STATES
WE DON'T KNOW. WE DIDN'T FIGURE
THAT OUT WELL UP. SO THOSE ARE
MY OVERVIEW COMMENTS THAT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS
WE THINK IT'S RIGHT ON POINT I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE PROBLEMS
OF THE EL CAP. HAVE ANY OF YOU
HAVE. SEEN IN ALL CAPS HAVEN'T.
I'D SUGGEST TAKING A LOOK AT
ONE. THEY ARE INCREDIBLY
CUMBERSOME DIFFICULT DOCUMENTS
TO WORK WITH THEIR RUNNING. TWO
HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED SOMETIMES
MORE PGES I AM GET TO MEET
SOMEONE WHO. IS NOT PAID TO
READ ALL CAPS PICK UP IN EL CAP
AND UNDERSTAND. I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S BEEN MARGINAL
IMPROVEMENTS AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON IT
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD FAITH
GOING INTO THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
BUT AS IT STANDS OUT CAP IS OF
AN OF I'M SORRY TO SAY APPLAUD
DOCUMENT AND NOT MEDIAN THE
MORE ARE NOT. SERVING ITS
PURPOSE. UP MEANT I OFFER A FEW
COMMON ABOUT WHY WE CHANCE. IS
SOMEONE. AT A PRINCIPLED LEVEL
JUST A REMINDER FEEL LIKE
SOMETIMES WE FORGET IN THE
POLICY SPACE THESE ARE PUBLIC
DOLLARS FOR PUBLIC SCHOOL
MONEY AND THAT A PRINCIPAL
LEVEL WE THINK ANYONE IN THE
PUBLIC SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEE
ALL THOSE FUNDS ARE BEING YOU
STE. ASIDE FROM THAT THOUGH
THERE ARE SOME IMPORTANT
FACTORS RELATED TO ENGAGEMENT
WHEN LCF WAS BORN WE WERE TOLD
THAT DECISION MAKING WHAT
HAPPENED LOCALLY BUT THAT
COMMUNITIES WOULD PLAY. AN
ACTIVE ROLE IN THOSE DECISIONS
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DO
THAT AS A COMMUNITY MEMBER OR A
PARENT. WHEN YOU LACK THE
INFORMATION THERE'S AN
IMBALANCE BETWEEN DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITIES. AND WE REALLY NEED
TO RECTIFY THAT. SECONDLY IS
COUNT. DID THE FUNDING. OR WAS
THE FUNDING USED IN THE WAY
THAT THE DISTRICT AGREED TO USE
THEM AND THEY ALL CAP WE CAN'T.
REALLY ANSWER THAT QUESTION
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO TELL.
EQUITY DID THE FUNDING HELP
THOSE WHO DESERVE MORE. IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO ANSWER THAT-
RIGHT NOW. AND THEN LAST YOU'LL
SAY VOTER CONFIDENCE UP MOST OF
US WHO WORK IN THIS SPACE ARE
IN AGREEMENT THAT OUR SCHOOLS
ARE UNDERFUNDED AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE STEPS TOWARDS
ADEQUACY BUT IT'S DIFFICULT TO
ASK THE VOTERS TO INVEST MORE
WHEN THERE ARE SO MANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THE CURRENT
FUNDING IS YOU STE WE'RE GOING
TO BE HAVING DISCUSSIONS FOR
YEARS ABOUT ADEQUACY. AND
ADDRESS WHETHER URGES THAT WE
REALLY HOME ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS FIX THE TO FIX THE
TRANSPARENCIES SO WE COULD WORK
TOGETHER ON A PER AT A
EDUCATION. AND THEN THE AUDITOR
REMINDED US HOW IMPORTANT
TRANSPARENCY IS TO PROGRAM
EVALUATION IT IS RARE I I'M
HARD PRESSED TO THINK OF A
FIELD WHERE YOU SET A GOAL AND
TAKES STEPS TOWARDS IT AND
EVALUATE THE DECISIONS ON THE
STEPS. TO TRY TO GET. WE THINK
AND SEE IS INCREDIBLE HELP
HEALTHY AND WILL MAKE ELSE.
MORE OF A FOR EVERYONE. AND SO
GLAD THAT IT WAS IN WE'RE HAPPY
TO PAY A SPONSOR OF DOCTOR
WEBBER'S BILLS IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU. WITH
THE CITY OF MORNING AT CHAIRMAN
SALAS AND MEMBERS THAT I'M
DEBORAH BROWN ON BEHALF OF A
REPRESENTING CHILDREN NOW WHICH
IS A NON. PARTISAN EQUITY
FOCUSED RESEARCH ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION WORKING TO IMPROVE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY AND ENSURE
THAT ALL KIDS HAVE THE SUPPORTS
THEY NEED TO REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL WE THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING US ON THIS PANEL WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK ABOUT THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR. AS SHE TEAM REVIEWED
THE IMPLEMENTATION ABOUT A FAST
AND WE THANK THEM FOR THEIR
THANKS FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS. THE ODD IT HELPS
ROUND OUT THE IMPORTANT
MILESTONES IN THE LIFE OF L.
CFS INCLUDING REACHING RECENTLY
REACHING FULL IMPLEMENTATION AS
WELL AS THE L. CAPRI DESIGN
WHICH HAS BEEN DISCUSSED WITH.
THEM WHICH SUPPORTS MAKING ELSE
OF MY TRANCE X. TAKE. UNTIL NOW
IT'S BEEN A STRONG OF LC SAID
IT'S AND MORE THAT WE- CAN TO
BE. TAKE THAT ONLY STRING. IT
WE WILLING STRONGLY AND I'LL
SEE IF. FOUNDATIONAL PER. OF A
FUN FOR ALL DISTRICTS THE
IMPERATIVE TO PROVIDE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR
STUDENTS WITH ADDITIONAL NEEDS
THE FLEXIBILITY TO RESPOND TO
THOSE NEEDS IN A WAY THAT
UNDERSTANDS THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
THE COMMUNITY. AND BE TO ENSURE
ENGAGEMENT AND TRANSPARENCY
THIS PART THOSE PRINCIPLES ARE
WRITTEN INTO THE STATUTE.
THROUGH THE FORMULA ITSELF
WHICH IS STATUS IS THAT BASED
FUNDING BY PROVIDING THE
SUPPLEMENTAL A CONCENTRATION
FUNDING. IT ALLOWS THE
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE USE OF
THOSE SUPPLEMENTAL CUT. DOLLARS
AND IT ELEVATES PARENT
ENGAGEMENT AND FAMILY
INVOLVEMENT AS ONE OF THE EIGHT
STATE PRIORITY. AS WELL AS
ESTABLISHING THE EL CAP PROCESS
THAT INCLUDES ENGAGEMENT AS
WELLS ILLUSTRATES HOW RESOURCES
WOULD BE SPENT TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE KIDS. WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE MUST NOT TURN
AWAY FROM OPPORTUNITIES TO TAKE
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED FROM ELSE
IF THAT ONE. IMPLEMENTATION ARE
A- PROVE MEANT AND WE MUST.
CHANGES AFTER THE NEED THE
WHOLE EDUCATION COMMUNITY. THE
STATE BOARD BY SYSTEM HAS MADE
STATE IMPROVEMENT TO THE L.
EMPLOYED OVER THE TO THE- AGENT
OF IMPLEMENTATION. IT'S RECENT
CHANGE THE LEGISLATURE WRECKED.
THIS IS WELL IN. INTO THOUSAND
EIGHT TASK IN STATE BOARD
PROVIDE THE TEMP. INCLUDE
CONSTABLE. FISCAL ACCOUNT A-
AND TO DO SO IN A WAY THAT'S
AND ACCESSIBLE TO PARENTS. THE
GOVERNOR'S ALSO. BY AT IN A PER.
AND RECENT BUDGET TO CREATE IN
ALL CAPS. AND OPENING CONVERSE
ON STRENGTH. ACCOUNT OF. WHAT
IS KEY IN MAKING THESE A- AS
THAT WE ARE IS THAT THEY ARE IN
FOR BY WHAT IS OCCURRING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL FOR DISTRICTS.
PARENTS AND COMMUNITIES AND THE
MAINTAIN THE CORE PRINCIPLES OF
ELSE FF WITHOUT OVER
CORRECTING. SO WAS TO PUT
BARRIERS THAT ARE INCONSISTENT
WITH THE INTENT. OF THE TIME
THE AUDIT ALLOWS HER FOR THE
REFLECTIVE AND CRITICAL LANDS
AND- LCF OPERATING WHAT'S
WORKING AND WHAT CAN IMPROVED.
THE FINDINGS RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR. A ROAD MAP TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE STATE BOARD
AND HOW THEY CAN MAKE THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS IN WAYS THAT
SUPPORT LC FF. WITHOUT THAT IT
A CORRECTION. WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE POSITIVE CHANGES
CD EAST BOARD AND STAFF AND
MEMBERS. FELT TEMPLATE
INCLUDING CLEMENTE COME THE
RECOMMEND. WE ALSO NICE THAT
YOU'RE BETTER CLARIFY GOALS IN
OUTCOMES. ON THE PLAN AT IN BY
USING THE TIMELESS DATA. ALSO
ADDING ACTION FOSTER IS IN THE
HAPPEN. WITH THEIR VERY
POSITIVE. HOWEVER MY NEEDS BE
DONE TWENTY RENTS. WHICH IS
COULD TO ENTER WHERE TO.
VESTING IN OUR BONTA TO POP.
AND THEIR WRIST THE OP IS THAT
WILL. MOVE OUT. THAT IT WE'RE
ALL PLEASE. SIR. THE CHANGES
PROPOSED IN THE BILLS DON'T
MAKE ANY CHANGES TO THAT
BROADER FLEXIBILITY THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT. THE DISTRICTS
HAVE IN SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION DOLLARS AND
ENSURING THAT THEY ARE USED TO
INCREASE AND IMPROVE SERVICES.
AND THAT THEY DON'T CHANGE IN
ANY WAY THE ABILITY OF
DISTRICTS TO USE THOSE FUNDS
FOR SCHOOL WIDER DISTRICT QUITE
PURPOSES. IF THAT IS AN
EFFECTIVE WAY TO ADDRESS THIS
TARGETED POPULATIONS. THE STATE
HAS INVESTED SEVEN POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION GRANTS AND STATE
BEGAN LC FF. AND IT'S TIME TO
HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF HOW
THOSE RESOURCES ARE BEING USED
WITHIN DISTRICTS AND ACROSS THE
STATE. TO FOR THE EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES. ENDING HOUSE
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
DOLLARS ARE YOU SHOULD NOT BE.
IT SHOULD BE EASIER THAN IT IS
NOW IT SHOULD NOT TAKE THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA COMBINING. NUMEROUS
EIGHT OR NINE DATA SOURCE SETS
TO ATTEMPT TO UNDERSTAND IF
DISTRICTS ARE INDEED INCREASING
AND IMPROVING SERVICES. FOR THE
DARK TARGETED STUDENT
POPULATION AND IT SHOULD NOT
TAKE THE STATE AUDITOR MONTHS
TO UNDERSTAND THIS. WE NEED WE
NEED TO BE. WE NEED TO HAVE IT
BE AN EASY PROCESS THAT PARENTS
AND COMMUNITY GROUPS CAN
ACTIVELY ENGAGE IN. IS ABOUT
COURSE CRAP CORRECTION OR
ADOPTION TO ENSURE FIDELITY
TELL CFF AND TING THE NEEDS OF
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS. AND THE
AUDIT. AND RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
CRITICAL INFORMING THE NEXT
STEP IMPROVE LCF. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
GUYS FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- LET ME
JUST ASK. A QUESTION AND THEN.
OPENED UP TO MY COLLEAGUES TO.
IT SOUNDS LIKE EVERYONE'S IN
AGREEMENT WITH WHAT THE AUDITOR
CAME OUT WITHIN THEIR- THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT IS THERE
ANYTHING ELSE THAT YOU GUYS
WOULD. SEE OUR TO SEE DONE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE- AND TENDED.
A RESOURCES ARE GOING TO THESE
THESE THREE THESE THREE GROUPS.
OF THE INTENSIVE IN GROUPS. I'M
I GET INTO THE JUST AS THE I
THINK PART OF IS ALSO ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT WERE NOT LIKE
I WAS TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW
OVER CORRECTING SO I THINK WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO SEE IS HAVE THE
RECOMMENDATION ALL OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
AUDITOR IMPLEMENTED. LET THE EL
CAP TEMPLATE PLAY OUT SO WE CAN
SEE HOW THAT'S WORKING IN AND
THEN MAKE ADJUSTMENTS OVERTIME
SO I THINK IF WE MAINTAIN THE
COURSE WERE ON NOW INCLUDING
WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED.
THAT THAT WOULD LIKE TO SEE HOW
THAT PLAYS OUT TO SEE IT IF WE
NEED TO MAKE ADDITIONAL CHANGES.
CHAIRMAN OF. WE DID DISCUSS THE
AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS- AS AN
EQUITY COALITION. AND US
SEVERAL PARTNERS WHO WORK IN
THE SPACE OF. THE WE THINK THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE. EXACTLY
WHAT'S NEEDED. THE ONE THING
THAT WAS MENTIONED WAS PERHAPS
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE. TO COUNTY.
SUPERVISOR ARTS I'M SORRY
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS. WHEN
THEY REVIEW THE EL CAP. RIGHT
NOW THAT'S- REVIEWED PRIMARILY.
TO SEE WHETHER THAT DISTRICT
FOLLOWED. THE EL CAP I THINK
REQUIREMENTS INSTRUCTIONS. AND
PERHAPS STRENGTHENING THAT
REPEAT SOMETHING TO CONSIDER.
OF IT. OUT PLEASE. WE
APPRECIATE THE PROGRESS THAT
HAS BEEN MADE ON THE AL CAPP IN
THE STATE BOARD AND WE HAVE
BEEN THERE PUBLICLY TO STATE
THAT SUPPORT AND APPRECIATION I
THINK OUR CONCERN. IS ON WHAT
OF A TRACKING MECHANISM AND THE
FUTURE WOULD LOOK LIKE- AND
THAT IS JUST A QUESTION AND
CONCERN. YEAH AND I KNOW WE'RE
ALL ANTICIPATING HER EAGERLY A
PROBABLY ANTICIPATING WHAT THE
ALL CAPS CAN LOOK LIKE WITH THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION IS
ACTUALLY DOING TO NOT ONLY
REVIEW THE TEMPLATE. BUDGET
INSURE THAT THE TRANSPARENCY IN
THE CARRABELLE ANY IS THERE FOR
THESE INTENDED PURPOSES- SO
WE'RE WITH YOU ON THAT AS WELL.
SO LET ME ASK YOU IS A
DIFFERENT QUESTION- WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT THE INTENDED
PURPOSES OF LCF FOR THESE
STUDENT GROUPS. BUT IS THERE
ANYTHING FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
THAT WE CAN DO MAYBE TWO. HOW
DO WE ALLEVIATE THE PRESSURE
FROM. THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
TRY TO GO AFTER THESE FUNDS.
RIGHT I MEAN IS IT. INCREASING
BASS FINDING IT I MEAN IS THAT
WHY. LIKE WHERE THE GAPS AND
WHY IT WHY ARE THERE PRESSURES.
TO TWO AB USES RESOURCES FOR
OTHER THINGS. I HEARD ON BEHALF
OF MY ORGANIZATION. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE
UNDERFUNDED-GETTING DOWN TO
FAX TO I THINK ESTIMATED AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS ARE OVER TWENTY BILLION
THAT'S REQUIRED TO PROVIDE OUR
STUDENTS INADEQUATE EDUCATION
SO I THINK WE RECOGNIZE THE
PRESSURES DISTRICTS ARE UNDER-
TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND WE NEED
TO WORK TOGETHER THINK TO PUT
MORE MONEY INTO THE SYSTEM. BUT
AS AN ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
MORE MONEY ISN'T THE ANSWER
ALONE IT DEPENDS ON HOW THE
MONEY IS USED SO- BUT I THINK
WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER ON THE
ADEQUACY. YOU AT. VERY MUCH
AGREE THAT WE WERE SEE FUNDING
FOR THE BASE GRANT ANY
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
DISCRETIONARY DOLLARS I WILL
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE USE OF
FUNDING FOR THE FOR OTHER
PURPOSES AS WELL AS- ANY
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS TO HELP
RELIEVE SOME PENSION COSTS. GOD
OKAY I'M MAYBE I'LL JUST ASK
SCHOOL GROUPS WHEN THEY COME UP
NEXT. LIKE WHERE THE GAPS ARE
WHERE THEY'RE TRYING TO FILL
BUT- THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
SOMEONE RECORDS OF A PLACE. SO
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE L.
CANNOT IN THE SUPPLEMENT GROUPS
AND- EVERYTHING RELATED TO THE
DOCUMENT HAS BEEN HAS BEEN
NOTED IT'S NOT REALLY-
NECESSARILY FAMILY FRIENDLY AS
FAR AS PARENTS KIND OF GETTING
BUT IT'S NOT ALL EVEN TEACHER
FRIENDLY. BECAUSE MANY MANY OF
THE EDUCATORS DON'T EVER
INTERACT WITH THIS DOCUMENT IS
SOMETIMES DONE- AT THE SITE
LEVEL BY A PRINCIPAL OR A
LEADERSHIP TEAM SO EVEN HOW WE
FUND OUR SCHOOLS PERIOD I WOULD
TELL YOU PROBABLY 80% OF THE
TEACHERS DON'T EVEN KNOW. IT'S
THEY HAVE THEIR CLASSROOMS THEY
HAVE THEIR CURRICULUM THEY HAVE
TO IMPLEMENT AND THE DECISIONS
EVEN HOW THE MONEY IS USED UP
PROBABLY WOULDN'T EVEN NORMALLY
COME UP AND REGULAR
CONVERSATIONS FOR TEACHERS.
BECAUSE AGAIN USUALLY DO AT A
DISTRICT LEVEL. BUT IF YOU
COULD SPEAK IN MIND OF PARENT
LANGUAGE WHICH IS OF. EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE TRYING TO IMPROVE
THE DOCUMENT AND OUTCOMES FOR
OUR SUPPLEMENT GROUPS THERE HAS
TO BE SOME TYPE OF DATA ACROSS
THE STATE THAT AFTER SIX YEARS
OF VIEW OF. KIND OF GOING
THROUGH THIS. NEW PROCESS OF
THINGS THAT MIGHT HAVE WORKED
BECAUSE I ALWAYS FEAR THAT EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE DOING ALL THIS
TRYING TO IMPROVE A DOCUMENT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE WANT TO
IMPROVE THE- THE EXPERIENCE FOR
NOT ONLY THE KIDS IN THE
CLASSROOM THAT ARE IN THAT.
GROUPS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUT FOR ALL OF THE KIDS AND WE
WANT TO KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME
TYPE OF PROCESS THAT WE CAN GO
THROUGH THAT SAYS YOU KNOW WE
THINK THAT REALLY WORKS.
BECAUSE WE COULD KEEP GOING
THROUGH THIS AND STILL HAVE THE
SAME OUTCOMES EVEN IF THEY'RE
MORE TRANSPARENT SO LET ME JUST
GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE. WITH THAT
AT THE STATE. THAT WE KNOW.
THERE IS A HUGE AMOUNT OF THIS
IS IN THE CLASSROOMS TO FOCUS
ON THAT TEST AND HAVE BETTER
ACHIEVEMENT BECAUSE THAT'S IN
ESSENCE WHAT WE'RE USING TO
DETERMINE WHICH I DON'T BELIEVE
BELIEVE IT OR NOT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
BUT THAT IS WHAT WE ARE DOING
SO THAT TEST IS NOW BEING.
TAKEN ON IPAD. AND I KNOW THAT
WE HAVE SPENT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. ON
TECHNOLOGY OVER THE LAST DECADE
WHETHER IT'S IPADS OR COMPUTERS
WHATEVER IT IS AND IT CHANGES
EVERY TWO MINUTES. AND YET THE
BASIC MATERIAL THAT STUDENTS
NEED IS A KEYBOARD. AND I'VE
SEEN OVER AND OVER SCHOOLS
AREN'T BUYING KEYBOARDS OR
THEY'RE HIDING THEM IN THE
CLOSET BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT
TO RUIN BECAUSE WHEN YOU TEST
YOU NEED TO HAVE ALL YOUR
KEYBOARDS WORKING IN THE MALL
CHARGE THE SOUNDS REALLY KIND
OF IN THE WEEDS. BUT THEN
SCHOOLS STILL ARE TRYING TO GET
MONEY FOR KEYBOARDS. AND
THEY'RE NOT EVEN TEACHING
KEYBOARDING SO WHO'S GOING TO
HAVE THE ACCESS ISSUE WHEN YOU
GO INTO THIRD GRADE AND YOU
HAVE TO WRITE US THREE TO FOUR
PARAGRAPH ESSAY AND THEY'VE
NEVER HAD KEYBOARDING AND YEAH
THAT'S ONE OF THE TESTING SO
HOW DO WE DECIDE FOR ALL OF
THIS. AND GET TO WILL ALREADY
KNOW CREATE BARRIERS AND ACCESS
SO WHO'S GOING TO TAPPED HIGHER
OR LOWER WITH JUST THAT ONE
EXAMPLE. KIDS WEB INTERNET
INTERNET AND HAVE KEYBOARDS AND
AT PRACTICE OR KIDS WHO HAVE
NONE OF THAT. I'M SORRY MISS
QUIRK SILVA I'M NOT HE SAID A
LOT. I'M HAVING TROUBLE
TRACKING THOSE IT WAS THE
REQUESTED OKAY AS I GUESS IT
WAS A COMMENT LIKE ALL OF THESE
DISCUSSIONS WE CAN HAVE THE
BOTTOM LINE WE CAN PUT MORE
MONEY INTO SYSTEM WE CAN DO
THIS BUT IF WE'RE NOT STILL
RECOGNIZING THE BASIC THINGS
THAT CREATE BARRIERS FOR OUR
KIDS AND MOST OF THE TIME
THEY'RE IN THE SUPPLEMENTAL
GROUPS. THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THE SAME TYPE OF EXPERIENCES
OTHER UP KIDS HAVE AND THEN WE
DO SAY NOW WE HAVE THE MONEY.
FOR IT WE STILL DON'T USE IT
HOW CAN WE FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSE THIS OPPORTUNITY
GAP. FOR THE WHAT THE ONE THING
I WOULD ADD TO THAT I THINK
THIS IS PART OF THE THAT THE
PROMISE OF THE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT WHICH IS REALLY. AROUND
TRYING TO PROVIDE THE SUPPORTS
REDISTRICTING THAT DOESN'T
DIRECTLY INTO YOUR QUESTION BUT
I THINK. THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
GETTING INTO WE YOU KNOW WE
NEED DATA TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING SO MORE AND BETTER
DATA- YOU ACROSS SYSTEMS WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT SO WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE ROLE OF.
EARLY LEARNING AND HOW THAT
PLAYS INTO THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
RIGHT FROM FROM T. CARE
KINDERGARTEN- BUT HOW DO WE-
KNOW WHAT'S WORKING AND WHAT'S
NOT APPLY BEST PRACTICES. AND
AGAIN I THINK THAT'S PART OF
THE PURPOSE OF THE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT IS THAT IT WILL- IT
TAKE THOSE DISTRICTS THAT THAT
ARE STRUGGLING IN IN VARIOUS
WAYS AND BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THEM. I IDEALLY YOU UTILIZING
BEST PRACTICES. I WOULD
DISAGREE WHATEVER ON THAT AS WE
ARE SEEING UPDATES TO THE
DASHBOARD WILL START BEING ABLE
TO IDENTIFY IT. HOW WE CAN.
SERVICE FIRST. COME. I THINK
YEAH. OKAY THAT'S SWEET. THE
THAT'S THE IN. OF THE OF THE
OKAY IN THE- LOW CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA AND ALL THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS WE DON'T. WE
SHOULD NEVER LOSE SIGHT THAT.
THE OUTCOME THE IT THE PURPOSE
OF ALL OF THIS IS SUPPOSED TO
IMPROVE STUDENT PERFORMANCE. OF
AN OUTCOME FOR KIDS IN IN IN
THE STATE WHETHER THEY'RE THE-
THE KIDS GETTING THE BASS GRANT
WHETHER THAT KIDS WILL GETTING
THE ADDITIONAL SUPPLEMENTAL.
THAT WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT LOCAL
CONTROL THE ABILITY OF
EDUCATORS TO SIT. AND TO DECIDE
HOW TO USE DOLLARS. NOT JUST
FOR THEIR CONVENIENCE BUT FOR
THE PROGRESS OF THE STUDENTS.
IS CRITICAL THAT ONE SIZE DOES
NOT FIT ALL AND YET AT THE SAME
TIME IF YOU DON'T HAVE GOOD
DATA. AND MOST OF
ADMINISTRATORS WILL IT NOT WAS
THAT THAT THEY HAVE TO HAVE
GOOD DATA AT THEIR SCHOOLS.
THEY HAVE TO KNOW WHERE THE
MONEY'S GOING AND THEY HAVE TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ASSESS THAT
DATA. IN THE PROMISED WELL AS
AT THE END OF YOUR TO DETERMINE
WHAT THE NOT. WHAT IS IT
WORKING. AND THAT ONE OF THE
REAL CHALLENGE IS THAT. YOU
KNOW WHEN WE WERE GETTING READY
TO DO. SO ADDITIONALLY THE L.
FF AND- I WENT TO SEVERAL. OF
MEETINGS IT AT SCHOOL. AND MANY
MANY VERY. AND TOLD AND I WAS
TELLING THEM WHAT THE INTO WAS.
DIGITAL DOT. AND THEY SAID WELL
GREAT THE MOVE TO GET BACK OUR
LIVE. AND WE'RE TO GO IN THEY
MEDIA HAD A LIVE OF THINGS THEY
WANTED TO GO BACK AND GET. AND
I SAID OKAY THAT SOUNDS GOOD
WHEN YOU HAD A LIBRARIAN OR
LIBRARY A NEW SCHOOL WELL AS
THE PERFORMANCE OF THE STUDENTS
AT THE TIME. ALL THE SAME AS IT
IS THE DAY OKAY WHY WOULD YOU
GO BACK INTO THEIR- WEDDING
THOUGHT ABOUT A JUST FIGURE
THIS IS WHAT WE DON'T DO THEM
UP AND GET ALL PIC OF THESE
THINGS I'M SAYING NO. YOU
SHOULD BE ASSESSING IT BECAUSE
I'M NOT SAYING DON'T GET A
LIBRARIAN. WHAT I'M SAYING IF
YOU GET ONE DON'T GET ONE LIKE
YOU HAD BEFORE THEY HAVE NO
CONNECTION WHATSOEVER. MAYBE TO
THE LIMITS OF STUDENT. AND IF
YOU GET KNOW SO. PEOPLE WERE
GOING BACK AND GRABBING THINGS
THAT WERE COMFORTABLE. UP AND
I'M SAYING TO THEM THAT'S NOT
WHAT LOCAL CONTROL IS ABOUT
LOCAL CONTROL ABOUT. SAYING IF
THAT'S A CASE AND CAN GIVE YOU
GOTTA GO BECAUSE IT'S OKAY YOU
MONEY TO LIVE. IS YOU MIGHT FOR
THIS YOU'RE MY FOR THAT AND
THEN YOU COMPLY. THAT YOU WE
TALK YOU HOW TO USE ALL THE
MONEY IN IT DOESN'T WORK. SO
RATHER THESE GOING. UP FOR MIL
YOU BASED. ON A WHAT YOU DO AT
YOU DON'T HAVE A GOOD DAY. I
DON'T KNOW WHO WHAT YOU'RE
DOING AND HOW YOU. IT IN AT
WHAT LEVELS EVEN IF YOU GET THE
LIVE AND DO THIS. TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S WORKING IF
NOT FINAL. SCHOOL THAT HAS WON
THAT WORKS. ALTHOUGH IS THE
HARD. BUT YOU. EVEN BEGIN.
PROCESS IF YOU DON'T KNOW. TO
DO WITH YOUR MONEY. IF YOU PUT
IT ALL TOGETHER. YOU JUST. IT
ON THE- THEN YOU DON'T KNOW WHY.
NOT THAT. THAT IS YEAR. WHEN WE
WERE DOING. I SAID THERE SHOULD
BE QUALITATIVE. AND
QUANTITATIVE DIFFERENCE AT
THOSE SCHOOLS. WE SHOULD SEE
MORE BUT WE SHOULD SEE A HIGHER
QUALITY OF STUFF. THE GOALS OF
THOSE SCHOOLS OF THOSE
STUDENTS. WHO GETTING THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. AND THAT MY GOAL IS
NOT TO TELL YOU HOW TO GET TO
AND THINK WHAT YOU MAKING
REFERENCE TO. I SAID IF AT THE
END OF THE EVERYBODY HAS TO BE
STANDING IN FRONT OF THE
CAPITOL. AND YOU COMING FROM
DIFFERENT PLACES I'M NOT GONNA
TELL YOU WHAT YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THE TROLLEY. WHAT DO YOU NEED
TO DRIVE. WELL WITH THE NEED TO
TAKE ABITE OF WHATEVER
DEEPENING A WELL FAR YOU ARE.
FROM THE CAPITAL WHERE YOU
GOING. BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY IT IS NON NEGOTIABLE THAT
YOU SHOULD BE IN FRONT OF THE
CAPITOL. YOU KNOW HOW YOU GET
THERE. THAT'S THE- CAN. YOU
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THERE
BASED ON THE STUDENTS. AND THE
CHALLENGES YOU FACE AND WILL
GIVE YOU EXTRA MONEY IF YOU GOT
IF YOU COME FROM FURTHER WAY.
AND IF YOU HAVE CLOSE. WITH
GETTING TO THE CAPITAL. IS A
NON NEGOTIABLE ISSUE. SWIM
PROVING SOON PERFORMANCE IS NON
NEGOTIABLE HOW YOU DO IT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE A
CONVERSATIONS AND THAT'S A
LOCAL CONTROL. THANK YOU I'D
LIKE TO QUICKLY JUST TOUCH BASE
ON- LEVERAGE FELLOWS COMMENT
AND THAT'S PART OF THE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT THERE IS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN HIM THAT'S BEEN
IMPROVING AND- I BELIEVE NOW WE
HAVE A COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION WHO ARE PROVIDING
THAT SUPPORT. AND EVEN AT THE
STATE LEVEL WITH C. C. E.
BEING- ESTABLISHED AND THE
GOVERNOR HAS IDENTIFIED HAS PUT
FUNDING IN HIS BUDGET SO THAT
CC EAT CAN GO AROUND AND SHARE
WE HAVE SUPPORT FOR YOU WE CAN
PROVIDE YOU THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SO. AGAIN WITH TIME
AND WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT WILL
START TO IDENTIFY. THOSE AREAS
OF NEED AND FIGURING OUT HOW
I'M WHAT BEST PRACTICES WE
COULD USE TO- TO IMPROVE THE
SERVICES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU GUYS FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY FOR ANSWERING
QUESTIONS APPRECIATE YOU GUYS
BEING HERE THANK YOU RIGHT WHAT
THAT WILL MOVE TO OUR NEXT
PANEL THIS COMMENTS AND
RESPONSES- FROM AUDITED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND- SO WE HAVE WITH
US MISS STEPHANIE. GREG SAN
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT STRUCTURE
MEASUREMENT BRANCH CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION- WE
HAVE MISS LISA. CONSTANTE CO
THE DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT
OPERATIONS ADMINISTRATIVE
BRANCH CALIFORNIA BERMAN OF
EDUCATION LARA MANDERSON
ASSOCIATE SUPERINTENDENT FOR
LEADERSHIP CLOVERS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT- SANDRA GILERA.
CHIEF ACADEMIC OFFICER OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
LEAK A LOT CHAU DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF TESTIMONY
THUS FAR. I'M INTERESTED IN
YOUR TAKEN PERHAPS WE WILL JUST
GO DOWN THE LIST AS WE HAVE A
MY DAD FIGHT IN THE AGENDA
PLEASE FRANK MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE GREGSON AND I'M THE
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
INSTRUCTION MEASUREMENT BRANCH
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND WITH ME IS LISA
CONSENT CO DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
OPERATIONS IN ADMINISTRATION
BRANCH. THANK YOU FOR INVITING
US TODAY IT TO SPEAK IN
RESPONSE TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT
REGARDING THE LOCAL CHURCH
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. AB
SOME CONTACTS THE STATE BOARD
OF A- WAS REQUIRED TO UPDATE
THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN WILL WILL
CALL THE EL CAP. TEMPLATE BY
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY IN
RESPONSE TO AMENDMENTS MADE BY
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FORTY
CHAPTER FOUR TWENTY SIX
STATUTES OF TOOK TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. NOT LEGISLATION RICH
REFLECTED A COMPROMISE
NEGOTIATED THROUGH THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET
PROCESS REQUIRED SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE ALL CUT TEMPLATE
INTENDED TO ENHANCE
TRANSPARENCY AROUND THE USE OF
FUNDS WITHIN ALL CAPS.
INCLUDING THE REQUIREMENT TO
INCREASE OR IMPROVE SERVICES
FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND FOSTER YOUTH. AS
INTENDED BY ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN FORTY THE NEW I'LL CUT
TEMPLATE WILL PROVIDE
UNPRECEDENTED TRANSPARENCY
AROUND WHETHER EXPENDITURES ON
ACTIONS TO BENEFIT LOW INCOME
STUDENTS ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
FOSTER YOUTH ARE UP TO PAR WITH
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING SCHOOL
DISTRICT. RECEIVE THE NEED IT
WILL PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION
WITHOUT REQUIRING A PERFECT
SHIFT IN UNDER THE POLICY
BEHIND LC A FIVE WILL THERE
MEANS. THE PER FOCUS THE
ADDITIONAL FINE PROVIDE UNDER
I'LL SEE IF. USED TO IT GREECE
OR IMPROVE SERVICES PROVIDED
HIGH NEED. I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THOSE CHANGES
BEFORE YOU DO YOU HAVE THE
TABLES THE NEW X. TABLE FOR THE
TWO TWO. I'LL LCAS WILL NOW CA.
LINE TO AND TABLE WHICH WILL
AUTOMATICALLY POP THE- PER TAPE.
THE EXPENDITURE TABLES SHOW THE
L. IS GOALS ALIGNED ACTIONS
TARGETED STUDENT GROUPS
INCLUDING I'M DUPLICATED
STUDENT GROUPS THE SCOPE OF
SERVICES SO WHETHER THIS IS
SCHOOL SPECIFIC OR DISTRICT
WIDE. THE FUNDING SOURCE.
WHETHER IT'S A PERSONNEL OR NON
PERSONAL COST AND IF THE ACTION
IN SERVICE CONTRIBUTED TO
INCREASE OR IMPROVE SERVICES TO
TARGETED STUDENT. ALL ANY USER
FOR T. ALL. IN TWENTY THE STATE
BUDGET ADEPT THE DOG. CLUE THE
IN. WHICH NOW PROVIDE OVERALL
BOX. THAT THE MAN BE.
MAINTAINED ALCOTT. WAS SACKS TO
THIS INFORMATION ALLOW POLICY.
RESEARCHER AND ADVOCATES TO.
AND ANALYZE INFORMATION ABOUT
ACTIONS AND EXPENDITURES WITH
IN ALL CAPS. THE CAP NOW
PROVIDES MORE GRANULAR AN
ACTIONABLE DATA TO ASSESS HOW
ELEAZAR ARE USING THEIR LCF
RESOURCES. THAT ACCOUNTING
CODES WHICH ARE TIED TO THE
ALLEYS BUDGET AND NOT THE EL
CAP. THE STATE OF COULD ALSO
PROVIDE.INSIGHT INTO HOW YOU
SAID THE FUNDS RELATED CHANGES
AND OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS. THE
CITY WAS SEVERAL PARTNERS IS IN
THE PROCESS OF HOLDING A SERIES
OF OUT REACHING INNINGS ON THE
NEW- CAP TEMPLATE FOR ELEAZAR
IN PREPARATION FOR THE UPCOMING
EL CAP CYCLE. WE ARE WORKING ON
PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES SPECIFICALLY
ARE COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
ON WHAT A QUALITY EL CAP LOOKS
LIKE AND HIGHLIGHTING BEST
PRACTICES FOR OTHERS TO MODEL.
IN ADDITION TO THAT I'LL COP
THE US LCF ACCOUNTABILITY
STRUCTURE INCLUDES THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASH BOARD
AND ITS SCHOOLS. A SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT. TO HELP LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND THEIR
SCHOOLS MEET THE NEEDS OF EACH
STUDENT THEY SERVE WITH A FOCUS
ON BUILDING LOCAL CAPACITIES.
TO SUSTAIN IMPROVEMENT AND TO
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS DISPARITIES
IN OPPORTUNITIES AND OUTCOMES.
THE RECENTLY TWO THOUSAND DASH
FOR SHOWS THAT SEE IF. WE WERE.
HELLO THE CITY IS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO PROVE EL CAPEN
LCF ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM FOR
THE BENEFIT OF LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND THE
STUDENTS THEY SERVE. A HUNDRED
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE THE
CIRCUMSTANCE HERE TO SPEAK MORE
OF THOSE ONGOING EFFORTS.
PLEASE THANK YOU- IN RESPONSE
TO THE AUDIT IN ANTICIPATION OF
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
SURROUNDING THE USE OF ALL CFF
FUNDS STATE SUPERINTENDENT TONY
THURMOND RECENTLY FORMED IN LCF
WORK GROUP. MADE UP OF
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS TO DISCUSS
WAYS IN WHICH THE AUSSIE FF
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM IS
PROVIDING ELEAZAR LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES WITH
FLEXIBILITY TO LEND SUPPORT TO
FOCUS AREAS IN ORDER TO IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES. THE WORK
GROUP WHICH MET ONCE IN LATE
TWENTY NINETEEN AND ALSO JUST A
FEW WEEKS AGO IN MID JANUARY
CONSISTS OF EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERS FROM A VARIETY OF
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING
SCHOOL DISTRICT OPERATIONS AND
GOVERNANCE. TEACHERS PARENTS IN
EQUITY GROUPS RESEARCHERS AND
PUBLIC POLICY GROUPS MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE AND SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN COUNTY OFFICE
SUPERINTENDENTS. THIS OF THE
WORKGROUP IS TO GAIN INSIGHT
FROM KEY STAKEHOLDERS ON WAYS
TO IMPROVE THE PROCESS AND TO
ENSURE THAT IS TRULY SERVING
THE STUDENTS IT WAS INTENDED.
LASTLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
SUMMARY INDICATES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE
ENGAGING IN A PROCESS TO
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL AVENUES FOR
STRENGTHENING ACCOUNTABILITY.
AROUND THE REQUIREMENT FOR
ELLIE ETS TO PROVIDE INCREASED
OR IMPROVED SERVICES FOR HIGH
NEED STUDENTS PARTICULARLY
WOULD ACTIONS DESCRIBED IN EN
EL CAP ARE NOT IMPLEMENTED AS
ORIGINALLY PLANNED. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE OFFICE IMPORTANT
WORK THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY PLEASE A
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I
THINK YOU HAVE TO THE COMMITTEE
IN YOUR STAFF FOR THEM
ATTENTION TO. I RELATIONS FINE
SO THE AUTO TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
OF THE WORK THAT IS GOING ON
AND SAN DIEGO UNIFIED. I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF SUPERINTENDENT
MARTIN AND THE SAN DIEGO BOARD
OF EDUCATION MY NAME IS SANDY
GOT ROGER AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED- MY COMMENTS WILL
FOCUS ON TWO KEY THEMES THE
FIRST TEAM WILL ADDRESS THE
FINDING SOME STATE AUDIT. AND
THE SECOND WILL ADDRESS HOUSE
BEAGLE UNIFIED IS LEADING THE
WAY IN CALIFORNIA. SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED IT'S A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THE EQUITY BASED FUNDING
MODEL FOR CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA. FOR THIS REASON SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED DEDICATED
SIGNIFICANT STAFF TIME. AND
RESOURCES OVER A PERIOD OF SIX
MONTHS. TO ASSESS THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE AND REVIEWING
THE RESULTS IT IS IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT THERE WERE NO
FINDINGS OF NON COMPLIANCE.
AGAINST SAN DIEGO UNIFIED AND
OTHERS HERE AS WELL. IN FACT
THE AUDIT FOUND THAT SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED AT HERE'S TO THE
PRACTICE. OF SPENDING ANY CARRY
OVER SUPPLEMENTING
CONCENTRATION FUNDS. FROM ONE
YEAR FIRST SUPPLEMENT ON
CONCENTRATION ACTIVITIES. THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE RATES BY THE
AUDIT REGARDING THE UNDER
REPORTING OF THAT SINCE THE
EXPENSES WHAT'S FROM THE
IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD. AND THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN RESOLVED AND
IT'S NO LONGER APPLICABLE UNDER
ALTHEA PFAFF. WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE FINDINGS AN
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION TO MAKE
ABOUT THE IDEA. IS THAT THE
FOCUS WAS ON THE INPUTS AND NOT
ON STUDENT OUTCOMES. AND YOU IN
A FIGHT TO. F. TO STRING LCF.
IMPROVE TRANSIT. AND TO PROMOTE
CULTURE FOCUS ON. OUT IN YOUTH.
AND WE SUPPORTED STATE EVENT.
RESEARCH ACTIONS WHICH A DOT MY
CATION THE L. K. THAT IMPROVE
TREND. AND. WE BELIEVE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO EXAMINE POTENTIAL
F. REFORMS TO ALTHEA FIVE
WITHIN A FRAMEWORK THAT
PRIORITIZES IMPROVING STUDENT
OUTCOMES AND THE AL CAPP RATHER
THAN RETURNING TO CATEGORICAL
IS TO SUMMARIZE WE AGREE WITH
MANY OF THE FINDINGS OF THE
STATE AUDIT WHICH AFFIRMS THAT
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED. HAS COMPLIED
WITH LC A FIVE AND A COLLEGES
THE SHORTCOMINGS OF THE STATE'S
APPROACH TO PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING TO CLOSE STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS. THE SECOND
THEME HIGHLIGHTS HOW SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED IT'S LEADING THE WAY ON
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SERVES A HUNDRED THREE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SIXTEEN
STUDENTS. ARE UNDER THE CARE OF
PERCENTAGE OF SIXTY POINT EIGHT
PERCENT. AND WE RECEIVE ABOUT A
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE MILLION
FOR THE PURPOSES OF
SUPPLEMENTING CONCENTRATION
GRANT FUNDS- ARE YOU SEE A TO
G. COMPLETION RATES WITH THE C.
GRADE- AT GRADUATION HAVE
INCREASED FOR LOW INCOME YOUTH
FROM 40% AND TWENTY THIRTEEN.
68% IN THE NINETEEN FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS THE UC EIGHT THROUGH
G. COMPLETION RATES WITH THE C.
GRAIN AT GRADUATION HAVING
COOKIES FROM 11% IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN. 53% TWENTY NINETEEN.
GRAD RATE IS EIGHTY NINE POINT
2% ABOVE THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE.
BUT LET ME BE HERE THIS IS NOT
TO SUGGEST THAT THE WORK OF
IMPROVING SUSPENDED CHIEF IS
ANYWHERE BEING DONE WHAT WERE
YOU IF WE NOT DONE BUT RATHER.
WE ARE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION UNDER WRAPS THE A
FIVE IN FACT SEVERAL NOTABLE
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS HAVE
DOCUMENTED THAT ACT WORK. IT'S
AT SAN DIEGO UNIFIED. YOU
CENTER FOR THE- OF SCHOOL FOR
EXAMPLE COMPLETED A CASE TO ON
SAN DIEGO YOU. THIS PAST YEAR
WHICH DEMONSTRATED THAT THE
EFFECTIVE USE OF LCF FUNDS IS
DRIVING IMPROVEMENTS IN
OUTCOMES FOR ON DUPLICATED
STUDENTS. ANOTHER CASE STUDY ON
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED BY THE
LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE
COMPLETED IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
FOUND THAT THE STRONG
COMMITMENT TO INSTRUCTIONAL
IMPROVEMENT IN A SYSTEM OF
HOLISTIC STUDENT SUPPORT ITS
BOWSTRING STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
BEFORE I CONCLUDE I WANT TO
LEAVE YOU WITH SOME VERY
IMPORTANT INFORMATION- SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED IT'S THE SECOND
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR EDUCATION
STATISTICS SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
SERVE THE STUDENT POPULATION
THAT IT'S COMPARATO TO THE
STATE OF WYOMING VERMONT IN
NORTH DAKOTA. GET THESE STATES
HAVE HIGHER PER STUDENT FUNDING
LEVELS IN CALIFORNIA ACCORDING
TO EDUCATION WEEK RESEARCH
CENTER AS PUBLISHED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. VERMONT SPENDS TWENTY
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED PER
STUDENT WYOMING SPENT EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND NINETY PER STUDENT AND
NORTH DAKOTA SPENDS FOURTEEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE PER STUDENT. CALIFORNIA
SPENDS ABOUT TEN THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE PER STUDENT.
BELOW THE NATIONAL AVERAGE OF
TWELVE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX PER STUDENT. TO
SUMMARIZE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED HAS
MAXIMIZE THE INTENT OF ALTHEA
FAT. WHILE THE AUDIT HAS
PROVIDED A STRONG UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW THE STATE IMPLEMENTED
ALTHEA FIVE. MOVING FORWARD WE
SUGGEST A FOCUS ON INVESTING AN
LCI FIVE TO ACCELERATE STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT I WILL CLOSE BY
QUOTING THE LEARNING POLICY
INSTITUTES REPORT TITLED THE
CALIFORNIA WAY WHICH STATES IN
RELATION TO ALTHEA FIVE
CONTINUE PROGRESS WILL DEPEND
ON DEEPENING THE STRATEGIES AND
INVESTMENTS. AS WELL AS THE
FOCUSED EFFORT TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY OF EVERYONE IN THE
SYSTEM. YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU. THANK YOU PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR AT GERMAN AND
pASSOCIATE SUPERINTENDENT FOR
SCHOOL LEADERSHIP OF CULTURE BY
SCHOOL DISTRICT ON BEHALF OUR
SUPERINTENDENT AFTER MIL FOR
ROLAND. AND THE CLOVER
STARBOARD OF EDUCATION AND WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY COMES BECAUSE WELL
AND- IN A STRANGE WAY ALSO
THANK TO JORDAN THANKS FOR A
HIS PRESENCE IN OUR DISTRICT
AFTER THE MONTHS AND HE WAS
THERE AND REALLY ENABLING US TO
REALLY TAKE A DEEP DIVE LOOK
INTO- THE- CAT- EL CAP AND AN
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM- I WOULD
ECHO A LOT OF BUT MISTER ROGERS
JUST SAID ABOUT THE ACTUAL
FINDING. IN THE POLICIES OUT
WHEN I HAVE THE RIGHT OF THOSE
I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT THIS
HAS GIVEN US A REALLY CLEAR
GLASS REVIEW OF WHAT IS BEING.
OF AT AND IMPROVED THE
COMPLETION OF THE EL CAP
PROCESS- HAS BEEN SIX YEARS OF
CHANGES IN DIFFERENT- TEMPLATES
AND THOSE SORTS I THINK WE HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH ROSS COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION STATE
MORTGAGE GEN. AND HOW BEST TO
COMPLETE THAT- AS A SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY SER
SIXTIETH YEAR AND WE GET
ENTERING OUR SIX IF YOUR
PRACTICE ACCOUNTABILITY IS
NOTHING WE'VE EVER TRIED A WAVE
I'M WE LIKE TO KNOW WHAT THE
WHAT CAN BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR ANY. HOW TO WOMEN AND BILL
FOR THAT AND SO WE DO A OKAY
THAPAR DETERIORATE THROUGH NO
FAULT. I CAN STATE LAWS FOR THE
CLOSED BY SWITCH BECAUSE- WE
ARE DIFFERENT SCHOOL DISTRICT-
WE ARE LARGE AS AS MUCH RIGHT
AT THE WHY WE'RE WHICH
ESSENTIAL. WE DO NOT LEAVE ANY.
SITUATION I'M SORRY RIP YEAH
BUT- MANY CONCENTRATION FUNDS.
JUST SUPPLEMENTAL. WHETHER YOU
PP OF A FORTY. PERCENT
CURRENTLY. IT'S BEEN IN EACH.
AS OUR- INCREASES AND WE ARE
GROWING SCHOOL DISTRICT THERE'S
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT. WE HAVE A
GRADUATION RATE OF NINETY FOUR
POINT 4% AND WE REALLY HAVE.
TRY TO INCREASE WITH OUR
SERVICES- UTILIZING THE ALL
CAPS ALL OF SERVICES TO THE
UCBCP- STUDENTS THAT- REALLY
THAT MNEY WAS. BEING DIRECTED
TOWARDS AND WE THINK WE HAVE
SEEN. AN ACHIEVEMENT GAP
CLOSURE NOT THE RATE THAT I
THINK ANYBODY WOULD BE HAPPY
WITH THEM WE'RE NEVER HAPPY
WITH THAT WE ALWAYS WANT TO SEE.
OF OUR STUDENTS EXCEEDING.
THINK THAT PLAN REALLY HELPED
US. I DO THAT- THE AUDIT DID
COMMAND CLOVIS UNIFIED VIRGINAL
TRACKING OF OUR SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDS WHICH I THINK HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE. I KNOW IN SOME
DISTRICTS. AND ARSES TO PRINT
AND IF- BUSINESS SOURCES SOON
RUTLEDGE REALLY CREATE A SYSTEM
WHERE WE COULD TRACK. THOSE
FUNDS. IN I THINK WE ARE
COMMITTED FOR THAT IN THE AUDIT
AND I THINK IT HAS HELPED US.
AT LEAST DETERMINE- THAT WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
SERVICES. AND THE OUTCOMES AS
BEING H. H. WE ACTUALLY CREATE
OUR OWN INTERNAL. OUR PROGRAM
IS ACTUALLY CREE OWN. AUDITING
SO. TO REDUCE THE DASH. AS WAS
COMMON BEFORE WE'VE HAD THE
DASH WORK FOR TWO YEARS. AND
WHAT WE HAVE REALLY BEEN ABLE
TRYING TO DETERMINE IS EXACTLY
WHAT STUDENTS THAT WERE
FOCUSING ON AND HOW DO WE SEE
NOT JUST AT THE END OF THE
YEAR. BUT ALSO ON GOING THE
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AS WE WOULD
WITH ACADEMIC ASSESSMENTS. AND
ACHIEVEMENT YOU DON'T JUST WAIT
TO THE END OF THE YEAR TO SEE
HOW WELL THE STUDENTS DID YOUR
MONITORING PROGRESS ALL
THROUGH. AND SO WE HAVE DONE
THE SAME WITH THAT- I THINK THE
FLEXIBILITY WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA STARS ACCOUNT CODE
STRUCTURE IS FALSELY SOMETHING
THAT. CAN BE UTILIZED BUT IT'S
A CHALLENGE THERE'S NO DOUBT
ABOUT THAT. FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO NOT BE ABLE TO
MONITOR THOSE- THE U. OVER HAS
BEEN COMMENTED BEFORE- THE WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TRACK CARRY
OVER AND HOW IT'S BEING SPENT
BUT WE ALSO WELCOME THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE- OF THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE AND WE
CAN- DO A MUCH BETTER JOB AS I
AS WE ALL KIND OF MAKING SURE
THAT DOES GO DIRECTLY BACK TO
THE STUDENTS- FOR WHICH THE
FUNDS WERE. AGAIN THAT WASN'T
HOW THE LAW WAS WRITTEN- BUT
WE'VE ALWAYS MADE THAT A
PRIORITY OF OUR CARRYOVER FUNDS
TO GO BACK TO SOURCES THAT
MAYBE WE WANT TO SET TO.
PROVIDE MORE FUNDING FOR THAT
WE WERE SEEING GROWTH IN. AND I
WOULD SAY THAT- AS THE FUNDING
QUESTION THAT THAT MR ROACH
JUST. JUST GEN WE ARE THE LOW
FUND WELL THIS. AND FRESNO WE
ARE THE SECOND LARGEST OVER THE
FOR PERSONS EXPERT SECOND
LARGEST BUT THE LOWEST. THE
QUESTION THE CAME UP EARLIER
NOW. THERE'S A WHOLE. SECTION
CAN HAD ABOUT. BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE BEING A THE TABLE
AND BEING. OF CITED. BEING PART
HOPEFULLY THE SOLUTIONS WELL.
THANK YOU. PLEASE GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DOCTOR
SANDRA YOU THAT I'M THE CHIEF
ACKERMAN. ACADEMIC OFFICER FOR
THE OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I'VE WORKED IN
OAKLAND FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
I'VE HELD VARIOUS ROLES
INCLUDING TEACHER PRINCIPAL IN
CENTRAL OFFICE LEADER. AS THE
CHIEF ACADEMIC OFFICER
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF OUR LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN. WHICH
INCLUDES STAKEHOLDER AND
COMMUNITY OUTREACH. AND INPUT
THAT GUIDES THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE DISTRICT'S GOALS AND
INVESTMENTS. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE A CONTEXT
FOR THE WORK OUR DISTRICT AND-
ACHES EACH YEAR TO ADDRESS OUR
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY NEEDS.
WITH AN EYE TOWARD IMPROVING
LEARNING. AND ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES. TO BEGIN OUR DISTRICT
HAS A HIGH PERCENTAGE OF HIGH
NEEDS. GIVING DEFINED BY OUR
AND DUPLICATED PEOPLE COUNT.
THE PERCENT OF STUDENTS IN OUR
DISTRICT TO OUR THOUGH INCOME
OUR LANGUAGE. LEARNERS ARE FOR.
YOUTH IS WE SET A PER. STRAIGHT
TO NEED IN THE COST. AS I'D AT
IT IS BASS. AS WE CONTENT. TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS ACROSS THE
DISH MEET. TO THE SEEK HOW
LEVERAGE INVESTED. THAT DELIVER
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES WITH THE
BROADEST REACH. EVEN WITH OUR
LOCAL PARCEL TAXES THAT OUR
COMMUNITY HAS CONSISTENTLY AND
GENEROUSLY SUPPORTED OVER THE
YEARS TO HELP US DELIVER THE
HIGHEST QUALITY EDUCATION FOR
STUDENTS. THE CHALLENGES WE
FACE AT THE DISTRICT AND THE
CHALLENGES OUR STUDENTS
CONFRONT EACH DAY ARE
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE OFTEN ARE
NEEDS OUTPACE OUR RESOURCES.
AND OUR OAKLAND COMMUNITY OUR
EDUCATIONAL LEADERS ARE
COMPELLED TO THINK ABOUT
SERVICES BEYOND THE CLASSROOM
AND BEYOND OUR CAMPUS GATES. WE
MUST CONSIDER THE FOOD AND
HOUSING AND SECURITIES OUR
STUDENTS CARRY. WE HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT THEIR PHYSICAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH AND ABOUT
THEIR ACCESS TO CARE. WE HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT THESE VITAL
ASPECTS OF OUR STUDENTS LIES
AND HOW TO ADDRESS THEM BECAUSE
THESE FIVE CIRCUMSTANCES AFFECT
THE ABILITY OF OUR STUDENTS TO
LEARN AND FEEL SAFE. WE ARE
PROUD OF THE INVESTMENTS WE'VE
MADE AN OPEN. PROGRAMS LIKE OUR
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS THAT
INTEGRATE ACADEMICS WITH HEALTH
AND SOCIAL SERVICES.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IN SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH SERVICES ARE AIMED
AT MEETING MANY OF THE OUT OF
SCHOOL NEEDS OUR STUDENTS HAVE.
ADDITIONALLY WE CONTINUE TO
EXPAND A PROMOTE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS ME NO WORK FOR OUR
STUDENTS BY CAR LINKED LEARNING
PATHWAY PROGRAMS. THAT HAVE
PROVEN TO INCREASE THE
GRADUATION GRADUATION RATES FOR
STUDENTS. ME EXPAND OUR
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS WITH
CONTINUE LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
IN OUR AFTER SCHOOL AND SUMMER
LEARNING PROGRAMS. WE KNOW THAT
THE CRITICAL INVESTMENTS HELP
TO ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN
THRIVE WE ALSO AIM TO SUPPORT
OUR TEACHERS. NOT JUST WORKING
TO INCREASE COMPENSATION BUT
ALSO BY CONSTANTLY WORKING ON
IMPROVE TEACHING AND LEARNING
DITIONS. THROUGH OUR FOCUS ON
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
COMMUNITIES AND OUR MENTOR
TEACHER PROGRAM. WE KNOW THAT
WE CALL TEACHERS THE MOST
CRITICAL RESOURCE FOR STUDENT
LEARNING. WE FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT THESE ARE THE RIGHT
INVESTMENTS FOR OUR STUDENTS
AND THE COMMUNITY RESEARCH. I
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE UNDERSCORED
THAT WE HAVE COMPLIED WITH ALL
STATE REQUIREMENTS AND WE HAVE
INSTITUTED A LOCAL MEASURE TO
TRACK OUR L. CFF FUNDS TO
IMPROVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY OVER OUR ANNUAL
INVESTMENTS BY ADOPTING A NEW
FISCAL MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. I
LIKE TO END BY SAYING THAT WE
BECOME EDUCATORS BECAUSE WE
WANT TO SERVE KIDS AND SUPPORT
THEM TO SIXTY. YOU WANNA BREAK
CYCLES THAT ARE PREDICTABLE FOR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS LATINO
STUDENTS SOUTHEAST ASIAN
STUDENTS ARE LANGUAGE LEARNERS
AND OUR STUDENTS FOR THIS FROM
SUCCESS. BREAKING PREDICTABLE
CYCLES THE MOTIVATION BEHIND
EVERYTHING WE DO AND EVERY
INVESTMENT YOU MAKE FOR OUR
STUDENTS OF OAKLAND. BUT WE DO
SO KNOWING THAT EDUCATION IS
NESTED. IN A LARGER COMMUNITY
CONTEXT THAT IN OAKLAND MEANS
TAKING A WHOLE CHILD APPROACH
TO CREATING CONDITIONS FOR
STUDENTS TO THRIVE IN SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE TESTIMONY FOR **** LET
ME HAVE. LET ME JUST BEGIN WITH
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS USER ALL
ALL TALKING ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THINK FROM
CLOVIS YOU SAID YOU PRIDE
YOURSELF ON THE ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHEN YOU DO YOUR ACCOUNTABILITY
IS AT BASED OFF OF THE EL CAP
TEMPLATE ARE YOU DOING MEASURES
ABOVE AND BEYOND- DEPENDING ON
WHAT PARENTS OR STUDENT GROUPS
ARE ASKING FOR. YEAH COMMENT ON
THAT NO I THINK I'M WE HAVE AN
INTERNAL WE CALL IT A CLASSY AN
INTERNAL ACCOUNTING ABILITY
SYSTEM THAT REALLY TAKES
ACCOUNT- ALL STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT AND ALL CATEGORIES
IT TAKES A CAN. STEP PARENT
PARTICIPATION- LOTS OF
DIFFERENT ITEMS SPECIFICALLY TO
THE EL CAP- THE ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS WITH
THOSE SPECIFIC SUBGROUPS ARE WE
HITTING OUR GOALS WHICH IS
INCREASE STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
THE STUDENT AND- I'M- AS OF MY
FRIEND FROM OPEN JUST KIND OF
SET IT THE WHOLE CHILD CONCEPT.
HI THIS IS JUST A SET WORKER
FOR CHIEF MENTOR- OR X. AND OF
THE FORUMS- I SO I THINK THAT
IS WHERE WE ARE ALWAYS TRYING
TO LOOK BACK AT OUR SYSTEM OF
HAS THE PROGRAM SYSTEM WE
PLACE. EATING THE NEEDS OF MOST
NEEDY STUDENTS AND THAT IS
FEEDBACK. FROM STUDENT IN A
PROCUREMENT. EXPOSURE TO ADD TO
THAT AYE AYE WE JUST SAY IN
TERMS OF SANDY UNION THE CAPEN
DEFINITELY FRAME TO HAVE A LOT
OF THESE COMMERCE IN TO ATTEND
AREAS TO AND BASS WE ALL USE
THE I'VE- REMEMBERING THE
ACRONYM THE S. P. AS SAY THE
SCHOOL PLAN FOR STUDENT.
ACHIEVEMENT PAN OUR PRINCIPLES
USE THAT IN COORDINATION AND
COLLABORATION WITH OUR PARENTS
AT THE SCHOOL SITE BUT THEN A
FIGHT NEEDS SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO STUDENTS AT THAT
SCHOOL SIDE AND SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED WE ALSO HAVE VISION
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH WE WILL BE
UPDATING WHICH IS OUR STRATEGIC
VISIONARY STOCK. THE HELP
PROPEL TO WHERE WE WANT TO GET
TO WITH STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AS
WELL GOT IT. THANK YOU. PLEASE
GIVE ME ONE JUST COMMENT IN AND
BEING THAT NON. CONCENTRATED
BUT IT JUST. IN THE GROUP IS
ONE OF ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT I WILL JUST ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT WE HAVE FOURTEEN SCHOOLS
IN OUR DISTRICT THAT ACTUALLY
HAVE- WOULD QUALIFY FOR
CONCENTRATION FUNDING AND SO.
THOSE CHALLENGES WE HAVE WE
DON'T MAKE THAT SIX AS WE HAVE
NO EXCUSES OR ANYTHING OF THAT
SORT I THINK WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT SORT OF THOSE SOME OF THOSE
CHALLENGES WITH THEM WITHIN THE
DISTRICT UNDER NINETY SQUARE
MILES IN PROBABLY ALL OF THE
DISTRICTS YOU'RE GONNA HAVE ONE
INTO THE DISTRICT THAT HAS OF
LOW YOU PP COUNT AND THE OTHERS
THAT ARE. THAT ARE MUCH HIGHER
AGAINST THE WHEN YOU DON'T
RECEIVE THIS ONE THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT LOOK
AS WELL TO CUT IT. I'M DOESN'T
THE DEPARTMENT REQUIRE YOU GUYS
NOT TO. OR TO DO SOMETHING WITH
THE PP SO YOU'RE DOUBLE CAL
STUDENTS. RESERVE THAT ALREADY
INHERENTLY BILTON THAT IS
ALREADY INHERENTLY BUILT IN BUT
THE- SO IN OTHER WORDS I GUESS
IF IT WAS FUNDED BY SCHOOL
RATHER THAN MY DISTRICT WE HAVE
FOURTEEN SCHOOLS RECEIVING
CONCENTRATION FUNDING. GOT IT.
ALL RIGHT- LET ME JUST ASK CITY
SO. YOU KNOW SOME OF THE SCHOOL
OBVIOUSLY ARE DOING SOMETHINGS
BEYOND THE EL CAP. BASS LINE I
GUESS ARE BEYOND THE TEMPLATE I
MEAN THERE ARE YOU GUYS LOOKING
AT TWITCH WORKING GROUP'S
BECAUSE I'VE LEVY COMMENTED ON
HAVING THE WORKING GROUP'S. IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
PUSHING FOR WITH THE STATE
BOARD AT HOW DO WE INCLUDE SOME
OF THESE OTHER MEASURES TO
INCREASE AT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY THAT'S- THAT EVEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE HEARING
FOR. WELL I'VE SAY SORRY
DASHBOARD HAS MULTIPLE MEASURES
INDICATORS. IT'S NOT JUST
AROUND STUDENT ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT YOU HAVE CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM RATE YOU HAVE
SUSPENSION IT YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
MEASURES SO ARE ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM IS NOT CONTINGENT ON
JUST. ONE MEASURE IT'S
MULTIPLE. AS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
CLOSE YOU TALKED ABOUT YOUR
PARENT ENGAGEMENT. ON CALL
CLAYTON SCHOOL AND CULTURE ARE
ALL OF THE INDICATORS WITHIN
THE DASHBOARD AND SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE L. COP IS
JUST ONE PIECE OF THE PUZZLE.
FOR OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
FOR US AS THE DEPARTMENT IN OUR
SUPPORT TO OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN OUR COUNTY OFFICES WE HAVE
THE YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID THE
DASHBOARD WE HAVE THE- THE
STATE WIDE SYSTEM A SUPPORT
WHERE WERE PARTNERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE. AND WE
ARE WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING THE SUPPORT TO OUR
DISTRICTS WERE STRUGGLING WITH
PROVIDING THAT FIRST HIGH
QUALITY EXPERIENCE TO THEIR
STUDENTS FROM THEIR LEVEL ONE
SORT RESOURCES. AND SO AGAIN
THEY'LL CAP IS JUST ONE PIECE
OF A VERY LARGE PUZZLE AROUND
WHAT ARE DISTRICTS AND WHAT THE-
IS. GOT IT. YEAH I APPRECIATE
THAT FOR THE FOR BASS THAT AS
BECAUSE IT SAID SOLD PEOPLE. OF
GEAR FROM STATE OUT AND YES
PANEL THEY WERE ME ABOUT HOW DO
WE DO THIS A- DASH FOR SOME OF
THE- ARE STILL OF THE- TARGETED.
LOOKING FOR. GAYS YET HOW TO
ALIGN THE IN THE WERE SEVEN CAN
WEEKS SOMETHING FROM CITY IN
AND THIS AND THIS SO IT DOES IS
A LIE. SO I WANTED TO SOME OF
THE- WHIMS AUDITOR AT SAID SO
REGARDING THAT THE ALL CROP IN
THE DASHBOARD THE STEPS STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION ADOPTS THE%
CRITERIA FOR THE DASHBOARD AND
THE COP. THE C. D. E. RESOURCES
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT AROUND THE DASHBOARD IN
ALL CAPS WE ALSO DO THE DAY TO
DAY PROCESS THE PROCESSING OF
ALL THE DATA BEHIND THE DASH
BOARD. SO IT IS A SHARED
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND SO
WHAT YOU SEE WITHIN THE
DASHBOARD IS WE HAVE MULTIPLE
STUDENT GROUPS WITHIN THE
DASHBOARD SO SCHOOLS CAN GO IN
AND SEE OUR ACTUALLY ANYBODY.
WE ALSO HAVE A DASHBOARD APP
YOU CAN GET ON MY OWN MMHM A
WOULD YOU ANYBODY CAN GO IN AND
SEE HOW THEIR ENGLISH LEARNERS
ARE DOING RATHER FOSTER YOUTH
ARE DOING SO THERE IS A LINE
MEANT FROM THE I'LL COP TO THE
DASHBOARD ALREADY CONCERNED
THAT DASHBOARD IF I'M LOOKING
AT ENGLISH LEARNERS LIKE YOU
SPECIFIED. BUT I BE ABLE TO SEE
THE ALLOCATION FROM THE LCF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDS NOW IT THE
DASHBOARD DOES NOT HOLD FISCAL
INFORMATION. OKAY SO IF I WERE.
TO SEE THAT. MORE WHAT I THAT
WERE THAT BE THE- IS THAT WHY
WE'RE REDOING THE EL CAP. TO
THE STATE BOARD OR- THERE IS
THE- CAT BUT WE ALSO HAVE
ANOTHER DATA SOURCE FOR OFFICE
INFORMATION FOR. US YES ARE
THROUGH OUR SCHOOL FACILITY OUR
SCHOOLS WILL SLOWLY SKEWS ME
SCHOOL FISCAL SERVICES DIVISION
WE ACTUALLY HAVE. A PORTION ON
OUR WEB. OUR WEB PAGE THAT
ACTUALLY HAS THE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ON WHAT THE
APPORTIONMENT ARE FOR EACH
DISTRICT H. L. EA. SO IT DOES
BREAK IT DOWN. OKAY AND SO. ARE
MY BATH FOLLOW UP WITH THE
AUDITOR NOW. ARE CAN YOU COME
UP. WITH OKAY. THIS BUT- THE-
ONE TEACHERS. FOR OKAY
SIGNATURE HELP ME WITH THE
DISCREPANCY HERE PLEASE. YEAH
SO THE DIFFERENTIATION THAT
WE'RE MAKING IS WERE WERE
INTERESTED IN IN SEEING A
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE SPENDING
THAT'S OCCURRING AND THE
DASHBOARD AND SHE'S ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT IN THE IN THE EL CAP
TEMPLATE AS IT EXISTS THE
DISTRICT IS IDENTIFYING FOR
EACH GOAL THAT THEY INCLUDE.
WHAT STATE PRIORITIES ARE THOSE
GOALS INTENDED TO ACHIEVE SO
THERE'S THAT ALIGNMENT. AT IT
AT THE HIGHER GOAL LEVEL WHAT
WE'RE INTERESTED IN FINDING OUT
AND HAVING MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT IS THE SERVICES THAT
YOU'RE- INTENDING TO FIND IN
THAT YOU ACTUALLY DO SPEND
MONEY ON. HOW TO THOSE SERVICES
ALIGNED WITH THE PARTICULAR
DASHBOARD INDICATOR SO AGAIN IF
YOU'RE SEEING EITHER PROGRESS
IN A PARTICULAR INDICATOR CAN
SOMEONE TRACK BACK AND SEE WHAT
WAS DONE THAT'S THAT'S LEADING
TO THAT SUCCESS AND THEN
CHAMPION IT AND CONTINUE TO
FUND IT. ON THE OTHER HAND IF
YOU'RE NOT SEEN PROGRESS IN A
PARTICULAR INDICATOR HOW DO YOU
TRACK BACK AND FIND OUT WHAT
ARE THOSE INEFFECTIVE SERVICES
HOW CAN WE MOVE OUR FUNDING.
FROM THOSE THINGS THAT AREN'T
RESULTING IN IN PROGRESS TO
SOMETHING THAT PERHAPS THIS
AGAIN IT'S TO ENABLE THIS
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
APPROACH. ADDITIONAL DATA WILL
HELP. STAKEHOLDERS MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS AND SO JUST TO ADD ON
TO THAT IF YOU SEE AN
EXPENDITURE TABLES SHEET THAT I
PROVIDED YOU YOU WILL SEE IN
THE NEW CAP THAT WAS ADOPTED BY
THE STATE BOARD ON JANUARY
EIGHTH THAT STUDENT GROUPS LCF
FUNDS. AN INCREASE WHETHER OR
NOT THE SERVICES PROVIDED
INCREASED OR IMPROVE SERVICES
FOR THEIR STUDENTS IS HOUSE
WITHIN THE EXPENDITURE TABLE SO
THAT INFORMATION IS ALL THERE.
AND THEN SOMEBODY COULD GO AND
LOOK AND SEE HOW THE SCHOOL IS
PERFORMING ON THE DASHBOARD.
CON AND SO FAR MY A BECAUSE YOU
KNOW I HAVE- GROUPS BACK HOME.
THEY'VE HAD THIS FIGHT IT THINK
THE LAST TWO YEARS WITH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT. HOW WOULD THEY
BE ABLE TO FOR THE CENTER THIS
THROUGH THE WEB. OR JUST
THROUGH. HOW THEY BE ABLE TO.
SUBGROUPS LOOKING AT EAGLE
SWEARS THE CIVIC LEE. AND TRY
TO SEE THE MONEY THAT'S
ALLOCATED FOR THEM AND HOW IT'S
BEING SPENT SO YOU'RE SAYING
IT'S AVAILABLE WHILE YOU
THEY'LL CULTURAL SLURS
AVAILABLE ON THE DASHBOARD. THE
FISCAL PART OF IT IS AVAILABLE
ON ANOTHER WEBSITE IT'S A ALL
CD WEBSITE BUT ALSO ARGUING
WEBSITE. GOT IT AND FROM THE
OUTER WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE THE
IMPROVEMENTS OVER THE YEARS.
AND THAT IS WITHIN THE EL CAP
TEMPLATE THAT'S IN THE NEW EL
CAP NEW LAND THERE THAT JUST
CAME OUT TWO WEEKS AGO YES
RIGHT GOT IT AND THEN WE'RE
EXPECTING FROM THE STATE BOARD.
EXPECTING ADDITIONAL
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES AND HOPEFULLY SOME-
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THE- OKAY. YEAH
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE THAT. I
HAVE A DISTAL QUESTIONS BUT-
THIS QUIRK SILVA PLEASE. FIRST
TO DR EDU LARA- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS BECAUSE I CAN
TELL HOW EMOTIONAL IT IS AND
YOU KNOW I THINK WE ALL SHOULD
BE EMOTIONAL ABOUT THE OUTCOMES
FOR OUR STUDENTS AND IT ISN'T
JUST THE SUPPLEMENT STUDENTS
IT'S FOR ALL OF THEM WE AS
PARENTS AND AS- EDUCATORS AND
TAXPAYERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WANT TO SEE OUR
STUDENTS ACHIEVE BOTTOM LINE.
AND THERE'S MULTIPLE MEASURES
FOR THAT LIKE YOU SAID IT ISN'T
JUST ON ACADEMICS IT'S ON THERE
SO MANY THINGS ARE FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS ARE IN A NOT ONLY NOW
BUT IN THE PAST. ONE TO SAY
THAT BIG THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN OUT THERE I NO WAY
ASK FOR THIS AUDIT BECAUSE I
DON'T BELIEVE GOOD WORK IS
BEING HAVE HAPPENING OUT THERE
AND ALSO I IN NO WAY BELIEVE
IT'S EASY TO TAKE SOMETHING AT
THAT HAS BEEN SYSTEMIC FOR
DECADES AND ALL OF A SUDDEN-
CHANGE OUTCOMES SO WELL OVER
TEN YEARS AGO BEFORE I WAS EVEN
UP HERE AS A TEACHER IN MY
SCHOOL DISTRICT I WAS ALSO AT
THE SAME TIME AIR OF FULLER AND
IN WE TRIED TO JUST LOCALLY
LOOK AT CHIEF AND GAP THIS IS
TWO YEARS AGO OR MORE. MAYBE
EVEN TWELVE IN THAT POINT WE
COULD ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THERE WAS
AN ACHIEVEMENT GAP SO WE'VE
MOVED QUITE FAR IN THAT SENSE
THAT I THINK THE COMMON-
DISCUSSION IS YES THERE IS A
PERSISTENT ACHIEVEMENT GAP
HOW'D WHO TACKLE IT THE
EVERYTHING FROM LIKE WE SAID ON
SELECTED TO READ INTERVIEW. TO
OF YOU KNOW SO MANY THINGS COME
THAT COME IN INCOME OUT OF
EDUCATION I FOR ONE WOULD TO
SEE FRIDAY COME BACK UP BECAUSE
I KNOW SO THE THING IT'S AND
BUT THAT'S MY LOOK THAT'S MY
LITTLE THING I KNOW- OF THERE'S
LOTS OF RESEARCH THAT SAYS IT
DOES MAKE A DIFFERENCE BUT THAT
BEING SAID IT IS BECAUSE I
DON'T BELIEVE EVERY SCHOOL THAT
SAYS THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO
BEST BUT WHEN YOU MENTION LIGHT
NOW WE NEED TO AB IT HARD FOR
PARENTS. YOU'RE NOT DOING IT
RIGHT OR OR WE DON'T LIKE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO SAY IF YOU'RE A PARENT AND
FOR MANY PARENTS WHO DON'T
SPEAK ENGLISH HOW DO YOU GET
THE BEST INFORMATION BUT THE
SECOND PART OF THAT IS IN THAT
LONG- TECHNOLOGY QUESTION I HAD
RELATED TO IPADS AND STUFF IT'S
REALLY ACROSS THE STATE EVEN IF
WE HADN'T ASKED FOR THE AUDIT-
WITH ALL THE WORK CAN WE START
TO SEE TRENDS THAT WE KNOW OUR
BEST PRACTICES. REALLY DO WORK
SO THAT I LIKE IS THERE A WAY
TO START TO COMMUNICATE THAT SO
THAT IF WE SAY WE WANT
EVERYBODY AS DOCTOR LEPPARD
SAID AT THE CAPITOL BY THIS
TIME AND WE'RE TRYING ALL THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS AND EVERYBODY
HAS THEIR KINDA LIKE LITTLE
SPECIAL THING HAVE WE SEEN ANY
OVER LINE. TRACK THAT REALLY
HAS CHAU WHEN THE GROWTH- AND
I'M TALKING REALLY MAYBE K.
EIGHT BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE WE
SEE THAT IF STUDENTS AREN'T
ACHIEVING. LIKE ONE OF THE
INDICATORS IS READING BY THIRD
GRADE THEN YOU'RE GOING TO
START TO SEE THAT FALL OFF
THEY'RE NOT LEARNING- THEY'VE
BEEN HERE FOR MANY YEARS AND
THEN THEY'RE NOT MOVING OUT OF
THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE PROGRAMS.
SO I GUESS THAT'S MY QUESTION
ARE THERE TRENDS OR PRACTICES
THAT WE JUST REALLY NO WORK AND
IF THERE ARE CAN THOSE BE
COMMUNICATED. DISTRICTS WITH. A
SUGGESTION NOT A MANDATE SO
THAT WE AREN'T USING HUGE
AMOUNT OF ROUGH AT REVENUE ON
ALL KINDS OF THINGS BECAUSE
THEY'RE INTERESTING BUT WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT THEY WORK.
YEAH SO THERE'S A THERE'S A
QUITE A BIT OF BEST PRACTICE
OUT THERE. WHEN THE MEMBER
ABOUT BUT PRACTICE IS THE A
BEST JUSTIN OPEN. MAY NOT BE
THE BEST PRACTICE FOR CLUB S.
UNIFIED AND SO IT IS ROLE IS
THE DEPARTMENT TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT ALL THOSE BEST PRACTICES
OUT THERE AND THEN COMMUNICATE
THAT TO. X. HERE'S A PLETHORA
OF ABOUT THAT WE'VE SEEN STATE
IN MANY. YOU GO. YOU KNOW WHAT
CAN LEARN FROM FROM YOUR OTHER
CALL AND TO. AND SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE ARE. ON IS THE
CAP THE NEW CUT TEN. SECTION BY.
PER HIGH QUALITY. FOR OUR DAILY
A ANARCHY OFFICE. ALONG WITH
THAT WITH THE BEST. THAT WE'VE
WITH THAT CAP AREA FOR INSTANCE
STAY COOL ENGAGE. WE'VE SEEN
THE BEST. ACROSS THE DISTRICTS
AROUND. ENGAGE WE WERE. FULL
DISTRICT AND SO WILL BE
COMMUNICATING. IN MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET ME JUST FOLLOW UP
ON THAT YOU KNOW I WAS LOOKING
AT SOME OF THE LCF REPORTS AND
AS WE WERE LOOKING AT THE
TARGETED MONEY FOR THESE GROUPS
AND I KNOW MISS WEBBER CARES
ABOUT THINK TO START ABOUT THIS
BEFORE LOOKING AT THE ACADEMIC
GROWTH THE ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENTS AND I READ
SOMETHING WHERE AMONG AFRICAN
AMERICANS IT'S ACTUALLY. IT'S
NOT MEETING THE MARK. AND SO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW CAN WE-
I WILL MAKE SURE THAT THESE
INTENDED PURPOSES OR MAYBE IT'S
THREE WORKING GROUPS THAT YOU
GUYS ARE HAVE NOW IT CD LIKE
HARRY TACKLING THIS ISSUE
THAT'S GREAT THAT I AM I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT YOU BROUGHT IT
AT AT BECAUSE WE'RE ACTUALLY
STUDYING THE TWENTY FIVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST
POPULATION OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS. WE'RE LOOKING TO SEE
WHAT FUNDING THERE WERE ALREADY
RECEIVING AND HOW WE CAN
COORDINATE SERVICES TO REALLY
TARGET WHAT THEY NEED AND SO
WILL BE WORKING WITH THOSE
DISTRICTS IN THE COUNTY OFFICES
THAT THOSE DISTRICTS ARE WITHIN
TO REALLY TARGET AGAIN WE HELP
WE HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF
COHERENCE NOW WITH OUR EL CAP
IN OUR DASHBOARD AND OUR OUR
STATEWIDE SYSTEM A SUPPORT WE
HAVE NOW HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDE COHERENCE WITH OUR
SUPPORT. AND SO WE WILL BE
TARGETING THOSE SPECIFIC SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO HELP THEM GET WHAT
THEY NEED TO BETTER SERVE THE
STUDENTS. AND IS THAT JUST
COMING UP BEST PRACTICES I KNOW
SCHOOL AS WORK FOR BUT SO IS
THE MULTIPLE WAYS WITHIN OUR
STATE RIGHT TO SMITH THE IT'S
AROUND CONTINUE IMPROVEMENT AND
FINDING OUT WHAT ARE THE ROOT
CAUSE SHOES THAT ARE CREE THE-
YEARS TO. FAST AND SO TO BE
PART WITH THEM AND CAR STATION
OF HOW CAN WE HELP WHAT IS
GOING ON IT IS THEY'RE SYSTEMIC
BIAS WITHIN YOUR PRACTICES IS
THERE BUT THE BARRIERS THAT
HAVE BEEN CREATED BY. I
POLICIES THAT YOU CREATED WITH
YOUR LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD SO WE
WANT TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE DISTRICT
TO GET OUT THE ROOT CAUSE
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT A BANDAID
FIX. ON A LONG TERM FIX IN
ORDER THAT WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT CREATED THE
ISSUE AND WHY- OAKLEY TARGET
SERVICES BETTER SO DOES. GOT
AND I THINK IT WOULD WILL PRO
NOT YOUR LOOK AT THIS AS WE CAN
TALK ABOUT THE L. CFF. BUT THE
HOUSE THE CUTS GRAY FUNDS IN
THOSE DE WHERE THOSE AREN'T
BEING REALIZE. WHETHER THAT BY
BEING UTILIZED. WITH ATTITUDE
SAID THE STATE ACHIEVE. AND THE
STUDENT GROWTH AND WTH THE CUP.
WILL BE ABLE TO AVAILABLE TO
THAT. AND YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
THAT AND THEN WE THE TREND.
THAT'S OUTLINE IN THE ODD. TO
HELP. SEE THESE THINGS. SO WHAT
I'M HEARING. OKAY WE ASK
ADDITION QUESTIONS. MISS PLAN
SORRY I HAD TO AT AND QUICK
MEETING SOMEONE ELSE. REALLY
FOR IN OUR LISTENING SOME OF
THE WHEN I WAS OF. REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S COMMENTS
CONCERNING- WHAT WE NEED TO DO
AND OBVIOUSLY ACCOUNTABILITY IS
AT THE TOP NOW OF EVERYBODY'S
LIST FINALLY WE HOPE. OUR AND
THAT THAT WE WILL DO THE THINGS
THAT ARE ESSENTIAL. I WILL AND
I THINK WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT DID SOMEWHAT
CONCERNED THAT YOU KNOW- JUST
REPORTING WHERE THE MONEY IS
AND WHERE IT GOES AND SO FORTH
AND SO ON WILL NOT IMPROVE
PERFORMANCE AND THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT. AND SO IN
ADDITION TO THAT I THINK AT
SOME POINT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
TO DECIDE IT REALLY HAVE. BEEN
TO EVERY CHALLENGE. ARE AND I
THINK IT'S E. O. HAS HAVE THE
SAME QUESTION IT THAT THEY ASK
THEMSELVES ABOUT IT. YOU KNOW
WHEN I LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT WE HAVE SPENT.
RECENTLY ON IT ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT AND HOW DID
NOT GO TO THE PLACES THAT
INTENDED TO GO. IT BREAKS MY
HEART BECAUSE- FIVE AND SIX
YEARS IN THE LIFE OF A CHILD IS
A VERY LONG TIME. AND IF YOU
MISS FIVE OR SIX YEARS OF. OF
SCHOOL. ARE AND GETTING
ADEQUATE SUPPORT THAT REALLY
IMPACTS YOUR ENTIRE LIFE I MEAN
IT'S- I DON'T THINK ANY OF US
WOULD DONATE FIVE OR SIX YEARS
OF OUR- LIFE. TO PROGRAM THAT'S
FAILING OR TO AN ENVIRONMENT
THAT IS NOT ADEQUATELY MEETING
THEIR NEEDS. SO WE HAVE TO YOU
KNOW I WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WE GO IF WAS SERIOUS. AND
LOOKING AT MONEY ONE THING THAT
WHAT MEN AND. ABLE ABOUT MAKING
THAT BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE. A
DECISION OF A RELEASED HIS
ABOUT EDUCATING THESE KEY. I
MEAN IF WE WERE ARE AND I'M NOT
SURE PEOPLE ARE BECAUSE I HEAR.
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THINGS THAT
THAT WE KNOW WORK. AND PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE THE COURAGE TO
IMPLEMENT THEM. YOU KNOW WHAT I
WE KNOW THE SCHOOLS HAVE TOO
MANY BRANDON TEACHERS. WE KNOW
THAT. TOO MANY AND EXPERIENCED
TEACHERS. AND THE SOLUTION IS
FAIRLY SIMPLE. YOU HAVE TO MIX
UP THE SCHOOLS. AND YOU HAVE
THE COURAGE. TO PUT TO PUT
PEOPLE WITH A NEEDED IN SCHOOLS
AND- AND YOU CAN DO THAT. BY
STATE LAW YOU CAN BE THERE. BUT
WE DON'T OF THE COURAGE. AND
THE SO THAT'S MY MADE BECAUSE-
AS WE TALK ABOUT THIS AND GET
THIS. HE UNVEILED. AND WE GET
THIS DONE RIGHT. AND WE CAN
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING ON.
THEN THE OTHER QUESTION IS
GONNA BE WOULD WE EVER HAVE THE
COURAGE TO REALLY EDUCATE THE
CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE
KEEP CHANGING THE STORY EVERY
DAY AND I SEE KIDS WHO SPENDING
FIVE SIX SEVEN YEARS OF THAT
LONGER IN OUR SCHOOLS AND NOT
GETTING THAT MUCH BETTER. AND
WE KNOW THE END RESULT IS KIND
OF WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN AND
OBVIOUSLY THE STORY OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN KIDS IN CALIFORNIA IS
TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE. TOTALLY
UNACCEPTABLE IN TERMS OF THE
CONTINUED FAILURE AND THE AND
THE CHIEF MEANT GAP THAT JUST
SEEMS TO BE PERSISTENT AND
NEVER CHANGING. AND EVERY YEAR
IN CERTAIN SCHOOLS IS ALWAYS
SOMETHING NEW COMES UP THAT'S
TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE. AND SO I
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY COMING I
KNOW MY DISTRICT WAS HERE AND
THERE WAS COSTLY WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES- BUT I KEEP ASKING
PEOPLE IF THEY REALLY HAVE THE
COURAGE TO A FOR CHILDREN AND
TO DO THE RIGHT THING. AND
THERE ARE VERY FEW ADVOCATES
FOR CHILDREN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE LOTS OF
ADVOCATES FOR OLD PEOPLE A- AND
I DON'T MEAN SENIORS I MEAN US
YOU KNOW THOSE WHO CAN DO FOR
THEMSELVES WE A LOT OF
ADVOCATES BUT I REALLY THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING- PERSONALLY
AND- GIVING US THIS INFORMATION
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WITH THE
TWO BILLS THAT ARE COMING UP IN
THE- ASSISTANCE OF THE GOVERNOR
TO. AT LEAST TO GET IT RIGHT IN
TERMS WHERE THE MONEY GOES AND
HOW WE ACCOUNT WHAT AND SO WITH
THIS ONE AND THAT WAY WE WON'T
HAVE ANY EXCUSE FOR NOT
ADDRESSING THE OTHER ISSUE THAT
WE'VE GOT THE RESOURCES NOW
WHAT WE GONNA DO. YOU KNOW AND
WE MADE A COMMITMENT TO ALL
THOSE WHO DON'T GET THAT EXTRA
MONEY THAT WE WOULD DO THIS AND
I THINK ABOUT THAT REGULARLY
BECAUSE WE WENT TO IT I WANT TO
COLLEAGUES WHO SCHOOLS WILL NOT
GET CONCENTRATION GRANTS AND
WOULD NOT GET THAT MONEY. AND
THEY WILL GET THE BASS GRANT
BUT WE ASSURE THEM THAT THIS
WAS SOMETHING THAT THEY WOULD
MAKE A SACRIFICE FOR BECAUSE WE
WERE GOING TO CLOSE THE GAP AND
IMPROVE CAL. AND ALL OF OUR
LIVES LEADERS OF THAT CONCEPT
AND EVERY TIME I GO TO
DISTRIBUTE IS NOT GET RESOURCES
IN AFTER TODAY'S I'VE LIKE
FAILED HIM OF A WE LIVE.
BECAUSE WE DID NOT DO WHAT WE
SAID WE WERE GOING TO DO AND
THEY US OF NOT RICH A SO MY-
WHY SO THAT WE CAN. OUR THE
COMMUNITY SAID THAT AND IF AND
WE HAVE TO DELIVER THAT. THAT
WE MAY. GOING BACK. EQUITY
RIGHT UP LET ME ASK IF ANYBODY
HAS ADDITIONAL COMMENTS EITHER
FACED A ANYTHING ALREADY OR-
BEFORE WE CLOSE OUT THE PANEL
OKAY WELL LET ME TO A LET ME
ASK ME ASK ONE LAST QUESTION TO
FOR THAT MY BE WATCHING ONLINE.
THE TO FIND ALL THE INFORMATION
IF YOU'RE ONE OF THESE GROUPS
IS TRYING TO FIND MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
OR EVEN SOME OF OUR A. B. R. I.
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS AS WELL
LIKE HOW CAN WE- WHERE SHOULD
THEY GO AND- WHO DO THEY ASK IN.
I KNOW WE'RE GONNA EXPECT SOME
CHANGES IN PROGRESS A BUDGET
WHICH AND THINGS LIKE THAT AND
THE- CAPS JUST GOT UPDATED WAS
JUST GOING TO CITY'S WEBSITE.
THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION ON
OUR WEBSITE AND YOU HAVE
STEPHANIE IN MY IN MY NAME'S
AND OUR CONTACT INFORMATION WE
CAN HELP GUIDE ANY. ANYONE THAT
NEEDS SOME HELP NAVIGATING OUR
WEB PAGE OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. RIGHT THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA GO TO MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS. THERE'S UBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE COME FORWARD
HAVE PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
IF YOUR PHILLY WITH AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE LET US KNOW.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED. HELLO
HI I AIR NOW DELAYED COUNSEL
WITH PUBLIC AT THE ADDRESS FOR.
INDICATES AB FIND SO THE EARLY
YEARS OF LCF BATH. THAT MANY
DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES ABOUT
FOLLOWING THE STATE'S LC.
SPENDING AND RECORD PORTING
REQUIREMENT. WELL WE SUPPORTED
THEM AWAY FROM CATEGORY FUNDING
IN FAVOR OF INNOVATIVE EQUITY
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. CLOSER
MONITORING OF DISTRICTS AND
COUNTY SPENDING OF SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION FUNDS AS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT THESE
FUNDS REACH THEIR INTENDED
RECIPIENTS. NAMELY HIGH NEED
STUDENTS. THIS IS PRECISELY THE
TYPE OF TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE I'LL SEE
IF I HAVE A ENVISIONED BUT IN
EXCHANGE FOR GREATER
FLEXIBILITY FUNDS. THE
DISTRICTS IN COUNTY OFFICES
WOULD PROVIDE INCREASED
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND ENGAGEMENT FOR LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS. WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE STATE BOARD
OF ED. NEW TAP MADE
IMPROVEMENTS WILL ULTIMATELY
REJECTED MAKING DISTRICTS
ANALYZE EACH YEAR WHETHER THEIR
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
SPENDING AND SUPPORTED ACTIONS
ARE EFFECTIVE. AND THAT THEY
MUST DISCONTINUE AND EFFECTIVE
ACTIONS LEGISLATION COULD
DIRECT THAT THE TEMPLATE
REQUIRE THAT ANALYSIS ANNUALLY.
WITH EVIDENCE. IT'S FOR THESE
REASONS WE SUPPORT THE
AUDITOR'S FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE
MONITORING ABOUT SEE IF I
FUNDS. ADDITIONALLY I'D LIKE TO
KNOW THAT IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN PUBLIC ADVOCATES ALSO
ISSUED A REPORT AROUND LCF BATH
MANY OF WHICH BINDING- ARE
SUPPORTED IN AUDITOR'S REPORT.
I HAVE A STATEMENT HERE THAT
I'LL BE LEAVING THAT HIGHLIGHTS
THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. IS GOOD APP CARLOS RIP
THAT CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS. AB
THANK DOCTOR WEBER FOR AT YOUR
YEAR AND TENACIOUS PURSUIT OF A
TRYING TO FIND OUT WHETHER ELSE
IF THAT DOLLARS ARE. GOING TO
THE STUDENTS TO GENERATE THEM.
AT THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION WE'VE HAD THOUGHTS
NOT ONLY ABOUT HOW TO MAKE SURE
THAT LC AT THAT AS A FUNDING
SCHEME IS MORE ACCOUNTABLE.
ALSO HOW WE CAN MORE EQUITABLY
DIRECT FUNDS TO ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS PARTICULARLY FOR
STUDENTS WHO NEED IT THE MOST
AND SO WE JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT. TO POLICIES THAT
WE'VE HELPED SPOT FOR AND THE
DOCTOR WILL HAS CHAMPIONED AS
THE AUTHOR FOR ONE OF. THE
FIRST IS TO ADD FOR HIGH NEED
SUBURB TELLS THE FF UP FOR THE
PURPOSE OF GENERATING A COP
CONTRITION. I GRAY. AND JOHN
AND. THE CLOVIS WITH AT WHAT
WAS GRANT IN HIGHLIGHTING THAT
EVEN WITHIN A DISK. BOB WILL
THERE'S ALWAYS THE MOST AT TO.
OF EL AT THAT. FOR CHARTER. AB
EVEN IF WE SIR. AB 1% OF L. C.
ELIGIBLE SUBGROUPS ENGLISH
LEARNERS. OF FOSTER YOUTH AND
LOW INCOME STUDENTS- IF THIS
AROUND IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
AND WHICH WERE LOCATED IS
SERVING 80% FOR EXAMPLE THEN.
WE ACTUALLY DON'T GET
REIMBURSED FOR ADAM SAID THAT
20% WERE CAPPED AT THE
PERCENTAGE OF LCF SUBGROUPS-
THAT. THAT ARTIST IS SERVING
WHICH WE THINK IS FUNDAMENTALLY
AN EQUITABLE AND SO WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT RATING YOU REVENUE.
WE HAVE AN INTEREST IN ME AND
MAKING SURE THAT THAT WERE.
THAT AND BE WITH REGARD TO THAT
LOW PER. STUDENTS AB AFRICAN
AMERICANS CAN TO BE PER SUB
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S NOT
REFLECTED IN LC. WE HAVE
PROXIES FOR RACE. WE DON'T
TACKLE REYES HAD ON AND THAT'S
BECAUSE OF PROP TWO OH NINE AND
OTHER MATTERS BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DESIGN
A POLICY THAT GETS AROUND PROP
TWO OH NINE WHICH IS FOCUSED ON
THE LOWEST PERFORMING SEPARATE.
WE NEEDED CON TRADE THOSE FUNDS
TOWARD AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS MANY OF THEM ARE NOT
LOW INCOME ABOUT NINETY
THOUSAND. OF THEM IN CALIFORNIA
NOT LOW INCOME SO WE JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THE POLICIES FOR
YOU ATTENTION THINK ABOUT AS-
CHANGES THAT COULD POTENTIALLY.
BE G. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
SPECIAL WITH CALIFORNIA'S
BOARDS ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT
THE POSSIBLY THOUSAND- SCHOOL
DISTRICT I AM KELLY BOARDS OF
EDUCATION IN THE STATE- I'VE
BEEN BEFORE I'D EDUCATION
COMMITTEES IN BOTH HOUSES- OUR
BOARD MEMBERS. ARE STRONG
ADVOCATES FOR TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- WE WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ACTIONS THAT
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
MADE IN TERMS OF THE NEW
TEMPLATE. WE WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THAT. THAT THE
TWO FAMILY MEMBERS HAD MADE TO.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS THROUGH THE
AUDIT I GUESS I'LL JUST UPON
ONE OF THE ISSUES YOU'VE RAISED
AND EARLIER ABOUT HOW THE
PRESSURES ON A SCHOOL DISTRICTS
OUT THERE- RIGHT NOW THE STATE
IS- FUNDING. PER PEOPLE'S AT
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS
BELOW THE NATIONAL AVERAGE-
THAT DOES CREATE A LOT OF
PRESSURE- YOU ARE OUR BOARD
MEMBERS ARE VERY INTERESTED IN
DOING MORE FOR THE STUDENTS.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH. THE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER ON HER TWO BILLS- WE
THINK THAT THAT SAYS HEADED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON- TRYING TO- FILLED
OUT THAT A FUNDING GAP THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA I THINK
THERE MIGHT ISSUE. THIS NO
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS BRENDAN TO
EGG ON BEHALF OF THAT VOICE- WE
DID WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE DOCTOR
WEBER AND ALL YOUR WORK.
THROUGH THE YEARS AND STAYING
FOCUSED ON THIS ISSUE WE
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUDITOR. THE STATE AUDITOR'S
WELL SO- WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
WORKING ON LEGISLATION TO
IMPLEMENT THE- RECOMMENDATIONS
ON IN THE AUDIT. AND BOTH WITH
THE POLICY COMMITTEES IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEES TO MAKE THAT.
MAKE THAT HAPPEN SO THAT WE CAN
CLOSE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND DO
RIGHT BY ALL CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA. FRAZIER THAT THANK
YOU. ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHERILUS WITH
TEACH PLUS WERE TEACHER
LEADERSHIP ORGANIZATION WE WORK
WITH FUTURE LEADERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR- CONSENT A SOME OF A
RECORD SILVA THAT IT REALLY.
THEY RECOGNIZE THE PROMISE OF
ELSE PFAFF REALLY ADDRESS
CATION CODE BUT- NOT BEING ABLE
TO GAUGE. FOR IT ON AN HOUR
WHERE ALL THE SUB ON COUNTY OF
FUN ARE GOING BUT HOW THEY'RE
WORKING IN THEY'RE IN WITH THEM
AND SO TO HAVE. A FULL. AGENT
WHICH WE THINK SO. TEXAS OF LC.
I'M SO WITH THAT THE VERY.
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO THINK
A DOCTOR WEBER FOR HER EFFORTS
OVER THE YEARS. WE HAVE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF SUPPORTING HER
EFFORTS IN ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS. OF THE LOWEST PERFORMING
SUBGROUP IN LOW SUPPORTING OF
LOW IT'S PERFORMING AT. PEOPLES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
THOSE REASONS WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BUREAU OF
STATE AUDITS RECOMMENDATIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT FUNDS ARE
FOLLOWING THE KIDS. AND THAT WE
HAVE THE- ADDED FUNDS GOING TO
THE RIGHT PLACE AS USUAL COUNTY
THIS IS OF EDUCATION HAVE THE
RESPONSE. OF REVIEWED. LOCAL
COULD COUNT BUT THE PLANS OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND WE TAKE
THAT EFFORT. HE ARE ROLE IN OUR
OUR GOAL IS TO THE THEN THE
NEED. OF WE SEE THEM A COMMA.
ON FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT
PERFORMING WELL AND FOR THE
DISTRICTS- WHO HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED ON THE DASHBOARD. OF
COURSE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROVIDED
FUNDING TO ALLOW US TO DO THAT
AND WE URGE THEM TO CONTINUE TO
DO SO. AS THE NEEDS AB AND FLOW
FOR THIS REASON- WE DO WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND YOUR COMMITTEE-
GOING FORWARD- WE ALSO WANT TO
ENSURE. THAT FEDERAL FUNDS ARE
NOT USED TO MASK WHERE SOME OF
THE FF FUNDING. GOING ON THERE
CAPS ONE THING THAT I WANT TO
MENTION AS WELL WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
THANK YOU. MISTER CHIN. FOR
WITH. AND WE SINCE. HERE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU THE SALMON WE
ASK THERE'S ADDITIONAL PUBLIC.
RIGHT HEARING AND SEEING ON
AUTHORED ABOUT TO MEMBERS THE
DIE. THE CONCLUDING REMARKS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WITH THAT GRANT
A ROBUST HEARING OBVIOUSLY THE
A LOT OF THE THERE'S HEADING
THEM WEBER HAS WITH ALSO THE-
BUDGET TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
WHICH WE EXPECT FROM THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION. THAT'S
ALTHOUGH THE WORKING ON- WITH
THAT WILL GO AHEAD AND CONCLUDE
THE J. LIKE HEARING IN THANK
YOU FOR ATTENDING TODAY.